parliamentary privilege and practices of
the houses of the eruptus regarding
reference you may make to other person's
inner evidence
the Evans are witnesses physically
present or who give evidence within the
Parliamentary precincts is protected
pursuant to board Constitution and
statute by absolute privilege this means
that you have an absolute defense
against any defamation action for
anything you say at the meeting whoever
you're expected not to abuse this
privilege answers my duty ask her luck
to ensure that it's not abused therefore
if your statements are potentially
defamatory in relation to an
identifiable person or entity you'll be
directed to discontinue your remarks
distractions Witnesses reminded
long-standing parliamentary practice
such an accountant says or make charges
against any person or any entity by name
or in such a way as to make him or her
identifiable or otherwise engage in
speech that might be regarded as damage
into the good name or reputation of a
personal entity Therefore your
statements are potentially defamatory in
relation to identified with a person or
entity we just you'll be directed to
discontinue and it's imperative that you
comply with that direction
members are enlightened decision to
start in order 218 that committee shall
refrain from inquiring into the merits
of a policy or policies of the
government or a minister of the
government or the merits of the
objective of such policies members are
also reminded of the long-standing
Parliamentary practice that shouldn't
comment on criticize or make charges
against the person outside the house or
an official Leader by Neymar in such a
way as to make him or her identifiable
we're joined this morning by the control
of your general Mr Seamus McCarthy who
is a permanent Witnesses committee and
today we engage Mr Ryan turbridy and Mr
Noel Kelly
Mr charity Mr Kelly have been advised at
the areas that committee will focus on
and they are on a list also payments to
presenters and Personnel Authority
specifically from 2017 today details of
Mr Ryan tobrady's contractual
relationship with RTE including related
payments and exit fees the process
related to the tripartite agreement from
2020 including his negotiations and sign
off the content of that trade party
agreement and the issue would be
underwritten by RTE
the raising of the associated invoices
and related payments the details of the
invoices and who were aware who is aware
of Sam
any instructions given by Mr Ryan
tuberty to Mr Noel Kelly and any further
discussions in regard in that regard
before finalizing the agreement
the call on the 7th of May 2020 and the
letter that followed from Miss D Forbes
to Mr Ryan tuberty and then any matters
arising from Material provided to the
committee in advance of the meeting or
materials provided by RTE to the
committee
I'd like to thank the witnesses for
appearing and welcome the fact that
you've attended there was no we didn't
have to compel your attendant
voluntarily before this committee to
assist in our examinations
and just before I asked Mr tubridi for
his open statement just to mention that
the documents have come later we were
promised him yesterday morning we didn't
receive them so members received them as
they were traveling here at this morning
and only had title in autumn in the last
hour just and the other thing I want to
set out is that the position of your
legal advisor your legal advisor you
know just remind them that the
attendance of your legal advisor is with
the agreement of the committee uh
they're not entitled to contribute or to
disrupt the meeting or interfere with
the conduct of the meeting in any way
so Mr tolberty just if we could have
your opening statement please of course
um good morning to you all and and first
let me thank you for exceeding to my
request to to come before you today we
felt was really important and to be here
um I've always believed in the
importance of Public Service
um I was brought up that way and I have
great respect for the Iraqis as an
institution I've come here as you know
voluntarily because I believe in the
work that you as a committee are doing I
don't say that in any other way other
than that I want to assist in every way
I can
I appreciate that you'll have a lot of
questions so I'm going to try to keep my
opening statement as short as possible I
begin by clearly and unambiguously at
the very outset this morning a state
that that I'm truly sorry for all of
this and for any part which I have
played
and be it consciously or unconsciously
and anything that has contributed to the
debacle that that we're dealing with
today
I'd like to apologize to the committee
that they've had to take this time to
deal with this matter today and to my
colleagues in RT and to my listeners
so given the events of the last three
weeks there is a lot that I wish to say
and there's a lot that I need to say
and so please bear with me my aim today
is to help correct and clarify some very
serious matters and I'll be relying on
my agent Noel Kelly here to go through
the figures and provide greater detail
I'd like everybody here today to
understand that the figures and
statements presented by ort over the
last few weeks in relation to my
remuneration have created a fog of
confusion
a fog of confusion over what I was paid
and when I was paid
and what I knew
and when I knew it
full transparency and disclosure on
Ortiz part I'm sorry to say would simply
have avoided so much of this
and I'm here to do one thing and one
thing only ladies and gentlemen and and
committee members and that is to set the
record straight and to call out some
untruths and it is my belief that there
are seven material on truths that I'd
like to address in the first is as
follows
this claimed that I did not take a pay
cut for Morty in 2020 this is not true
I took a 20 pay cut for more Chief in my
20 to 20 to 2025 contract simple as that
I took a 20 pay code for Morty I'm
obliged to do and present 205 radio
shows and 38 as it was then live two
hour late late shows onto this contract
I am what's called an independent
contractor
I get no pension or entitlement for
Morty that's the nature of it under the
terms of my contract I'm allowed to do
additional work outside of orti that's
also the nature of it and I stress that
there is nothing morally apathy or
legally wrong with me or any independent
contractor doing additional work for
another client outside of RTE but to be
clear I took a pay cut for Morty of 20
in 2020 for each of the five years of my
contract at a cost of 525 000 Euro to me
over the length of that contract
I'll move on to my second untruth
the suggestion that my decision to
retire from The Late Late Show was
prompted by this whole debacle
this is not remotely true
I wasn't aware of any of this Fiasco
when I decided to retire from The Late
Late Show
I made my initial decision to leave The
Late Late Show pretty much a year ago
it was very personal
it was made in the heart and in the soul
around this time I mentioned it to those
closest to me my family and my agent and
and a few others and they were surprised
they were very surprised why would you
leave such a show
and I explained to them and eventually
brought them around to my way of
thinking that among other things I left
a lot of me on the floor in the studio
after covet and during covet I was burnt
out of being honest with you and I was
exhausted
a lot of people in this country as you
know were burnt out and exhausted after
covert doing a lot more important jobs
than I was doing but I'm just telling
you from where I'm coming from
so I turned it over in my mind over a
few months but by the time I got to
January there was no turning over in my
mind I knew it was time to go I made the
decision and just just to make it a
abundantly clear there is zero
connection between my departure and this
very raw situation of recent weeks I
informed Management on March 13th of
this year
I first became aware of this Grant
Thornton review in May some two months
later and even then I had no inkling up
the bombshell which was to come minority
released their statement on June 22nd
the Third on truth is that I was
covertly or secretly overpaid by RT this
is not true
I was not overpaid by RT at any point I
fully accept I'm very very well paid I
understand that
but I was fully paid
in accordance with my contract which my
agent agent negotiated openly and
honestly and in good faith there are no
overpayments now there are Ortiz under
declarations
which we challenge them on back in 2020
and there are indeed Ortiz over
Declarations of which they actually paid
me in 2020 in 2021 this has caused
justifiable anger among my colleagues
I understand that
and we're going to deal with all of that
in the next few hours and indeed the
next six hours or more we'll stay for as
long as it takes
the upshot of RT's inaccurate
declarations is an impression that I've
been less than honest this is not the
case the fourth untruth is that I was
aware that RT were trying to conceal
payments to me this is not true I was
not aware that RT were concealing
payments to me or to acknowledge this in
their statement of June 22nd 2023 when
they stated that Grant Thornton had made
no findings against me
the fifth on truth there was a secret
agreement with Renault that I tried to
conceal this is not true
but not only that
it Beggars belief think about it I had a
separate commercial agreement with
Renault the basis of which was that I
would make public appearances
and perform Road shows and things for
them and the work that I've done for
Renault is all over social media the
suggestion that was a secret
makes no sense
the sixth on on truth
that RT's underwriting of renault's
payment obligations was a secret
this is not true RT's underwriting of
Reynolds payment obligations was not a
secret as the documents we've prepared
for you Today's Show
and as my agent will explain in more
detail RTE committed
in February 2020 to provide this
guarantee in the early stages of
contract negotiations around my 2020-25
contract this is unequivocally confirmed
in an email data critical document 20th
of February 2020. from Brita O'Keefe
to my agent it was copied to other
members of the executive board the
director General the De Ortiz solicitors
office everyone in RTE who needed to
know
new
you'll find this on page 10 of the
booklet of documents you have in front
of you
far from being secret it was well known
and finally the seventh on truth that I
did not ask warranty about their under
Declarations of my earnings
when they released the 2017-18 and 19
earnings as they did all in one day
January 20th 2021
this is a question I did not ask at the
time this is a question I should have
asked I fully fully accept that
but I will try and explain briefly and
as clearly as humanly possible
at the end of the 2015 to 20 contract my
agent advised me that I was entitled to
a phenomenally large figure payment of
120 000 Euro that has been variously
called a loyalty or an end of contract
or a an exit payment
I did not invoice for that payment I did
not pursue that payment and I did not
receive any payment
the documents provided to you bear this
out in my simple view I had forgotten
that payment for 120 000 Europe not
taken it but because of how RTE reported
that decision in their accounts okay
here look The Narrative of the last
three weeks has been that not only did I
take this payment
but that I somehow contrived to hide it
so let me reiterate I actually waved my
entitlement to this payment and I didn't
receive one cent of it I hid nothing I
had nothing to hide
as the evidence provided to you today
shows
my agent had already pointed out to RT
in 2020 that we thought the manner in
which they were planning to account for
my earnings in 2017 18 and 19 was
incorrect and we had understood that
they accepted our position so that by
the time they released the figures I
assumed that the Chief Financial Officer
the financial Professionals in RTE and
the external auditors
who had ordered the accounts in these
years 17 18 19 had accountancy reasons
for accounting for it the way they did
so I'd like to add that my company
earnings fully reflect
what I earned in these and all
subsequent years
and particularly upset and disappointed
about the decision and framing of the RT
statement of June 22nd which
inextricably linked my name to this
whole Fiasco
my name was mentioned 15 times in that
statement
15 times
and I was not consulted
once
I did not have the grand Thornton report
which George he had and majority
acknowledged made no findings of
wrongdoing on my part
I asked orti to clarify that this was
the case they did
four days
four days after much of the day much of
the damage was done pretty much all of
the damage was done
I signed a contract in good faith I
declared my earnings I paid every cent
of tax
my employer has acknowledged that it has
engaged in deceptive practices to pay me
practices that were hidden from me
the result I'm nearly finished forgive
me for overgoing the result of this is
that I've become the face of a national
Scandal I've been accused of being
complicit deceitful and dishonest I
think the statement of June the 22nd was
very unhelpful in this regard the full
truth was concealed
I take full responsibility
I can't say it enough
I take full responsibility for not
asking more questions back on January
the 20th 2021 when the figures for that
2017-18 and 19 were released I take
responsibility for that I understand
but as has become abundantly clear and
obvious in the last three weeks
this highlights the existence of two
rtes
two there are those who are involved in
attempting to conceal payments and who
are in a position to call me or call my
agent and ask for our help in
establishing
full facts
instead they chose to hurriedly issue a
d and deeply deeply damaging statement
on June 22nd which failed to include the
fall facts I have nothing but respect
and aberration for that great number of
decent hard-working people in RT my
colleagues my friends
and I'm very sorry for those whose lives
have been made difficult with an
incessant dripping of New Revelations
I'm thinking particularly of my radio
show colleagues and Friends
that they've had to be put through all
of this for reasons not of their own
making they work hard they all work hard
in RT and I want to thank those
colleagues who've supported me through
these last few weeks and in closing I'd
like to thank
the many people from across the country
who've taken time to stop me on the
street
decent Irish citizens taking my shoulder
and my elbow in their hands and saying
you'll get through this
I have nearly a foot off the ground High
Ground high of cards and letters from
people who have written to Ryan tuberty
Dublin
and I got them fair play to the post
people in on post and I thank the Irish
people for that I'm hopeful that they
will see from my stipend and my
appearance here today that I am
determined to inform them of the truth
and to demonstrate that I have nothing
to hide and I'm also hopeful that I will
soon get back on air to do the job I
love
thank you all for your patience thank
you Mr Roberti uh Mr Kelly no it's
normally five minutes for opening
statements and we've gone 15 minutes
into it so I would ask you to uh it's
already five minutes for them so I would
ask you to
um you know to try and be brief as brief
as you can really please
but we do want to give you the
opportunity because we realize that
you're you know you're here today to
thank you but it's your side so please
cooperate
um I just want to Echo everything Ryan
says and I'm sorry that we're here today
as well
we asked to come and to meet the house
because of huge respect for our friend
and we haven't spoken to anybody else we
just wanted to get the opportunity to
put our site across
I'll try and breathe brief as I possibly
can but
um if you'll allow me soak Hurlock and
deputies
thank you for the opportunity to meet
with you today I hope this meeting will
help to clarify the confusion which has
arisen over the past few weeks
at the outset I want to say that we
appreciate the seriousness of all of
these issues
the controversy over the past few weeks
has been damaging to RTE
but it's also been hugely damaging
to Ryan property
to myself and to my own business
earlier today we circulated a pack which
we believe in the key documents that
will help you understand this crisis
the document runs 39 pages and it
includes relevant accepts Ryan's 2015
and 2020 contracts with RTE
extracts from their cancer blinds
company for the relevant years various
males which track the back and forth the
negotiations for the 2020 orti contract
with Renault
we've made reductions where necessary
but we've been as transparent as
possible to inform you with all the
information at our disposal
I want to highlight a number of
documents which we go which will go to
the heart of the issues
let me start with Ryan's under
Declaration of payments made to Ryan
when they were published figures for 17
18 19 and in January 21.
this issue has caused a lot of distress
and it's entirely a massive Ortiz Zone
making
Ryan's contract from 2015 pages one to
four of the pack
clearly states
the fees he received in each of the
following five years and they're set out
in Clause 8.1 of the contract
it was
495-495-545-545-545 for the five years
he received those fees exactly
nothing more and nothing less
this is confirmed of the extracts from
Ryan's filed accounts company Twitter
Productions which we also include in the
pack
we note that the accounts of total
Productions run from January to December
whereas Ortiz contract ran from
September
in January 21 when Orting made its
incorrect declarations they knew what
they had paid Ryan
indeed the Chief Financial Officer
emailed us on the 19th of December 2019
on page five in the in the pack
she set out the actual earnings for each
of the relevant years correctly but just
over a year later in January 2021 our
team made falter incorrect declarations
about the same figures
in some respects this was an accident
rate to happen we'd previously asked ort
to give us reasonable notice when they
plan to publish figures my email on the
16th of January 2020 page six of them
packed specifically requests this
we would have time to check the figures
and avoid errors however or to ignored
our request for reasons I still don't
understand
in March 2020
we saw the first sign that OTA with all
its accountants and Auditors might be
struggling to understand the request the
correct accounting treatment for what
they paid Ryan in 2017-2018 and 2019.
that month they sent us a letter about
Exit 3 bonus Ryan was due as part of his
2015 contract it was agreed that Ryan
was not going to raise an invoice for
this and they wanted to agree how to
explain it but in the draft which was
sent was they proposed to change the
payments which they made to run already
effectively lowering them by 120 000
Euros their logic was that they could
offset 120 000 we had agreed not to ask
for in 2020 against payments which had
already been made to Ryan for 17 18 and
19. we urge it against this and they
accepted our points at the time this is
clear from the document Pages 6 14 to 16
of our pack for some reason however it
looks like the confused thinking
returned and they published again the
wrong figures in January 2021
effectively causing his reputation
damage to ride in the process huge
reputational damage sorry
one important point I should add just
last month on the 23rd of June RT
published new figures effectively they
restated figures for payments to run for
17 18 and 19 and added in decorations
for figures paid him in 20 and 21.
bizarrely the figures they declare for
about 20 and 21 are wrong in both years
they overstate the amount they paid Ryan
and we addressed this issue in page 28
and 29 of the pack for 2020 they
overstated earnings of 62 536 for 21
they overstated 83 381 so clearly orti
is still struggling with these
declarations
now let's turn to the rental contract
which ran parallel to the 2020 contract
which Ryan had Authority I refer you to
page five of the pack
this is an email sent to NK Management
on the 19th of December 2019 from Ortiz
then Chief Financial Officer Miss
breeder O'Keefe this email sets or T's
starting position for negotiations on
the 2020 contract
you will see that this email is where
the idea of a commercial sponsorship
third party with an annual fee of 75 000
Euros is first suggested
this comes from RTE
this did not strike us as unusual as
Renault was a key sponsor for RTE so it
was understandable that they would try
to wish to ensure that all parties were
aligned
next we come to orti's decision to
underwrite this Renault contract this is
perhaps
the most shocking revelation of this
morning
since this controversy again
already tried to distance themselves
from this decision effectively they have
blamed the former director General D
Forbes for doing a solo run and giving a
verbal commitment to underwrite the
contract on a zoom call in May
ort Executives had said that there was a
strong pushback
against the idea of underwriting the
agreement
that is incorrect I refer you to page 10
of the pack
so at the time from the spiritual Keith
was the Chief Financial Officer of RTE
on this page you will see an email which
she sent to my office dated the 20th of
February
2020 it is copied to another member of
the executive board
the then director General an OT
solicitor in this email must be O'Keefe
responds in red to various points which
had been discussed she states at the top
of the email that this is our final
position because negotiations go back
and forth back and forth this is our
final position in respect in respect of
the new contract
on the last paragraph on this page Miss
O'Keefe on behalf of RTE States
explicitly we can provide you with a
side letter to underwrite this fee for
the duration of the contract
there was no secret
there is no secret
to our surprise Mr Keith told the
committee last week
when she left OTA in March that there
was no support to provide that type of
guarantee and no such guarantee was on
offer but she had written to us making
exactly that offer a month earlier
last week nobody for more te here with
Miss O'Keefe challenged her when she
said that
and we were surprised too
because on the 30th of June
four days before she appeared at the
media committee we wrote to OT and
highlighted the significance of Miss
O'Keefe's email
her email also casts a new light on the
contribution of Adrian Lynch deputy
director General to this committee
Mr Lynch told the committee that
agreement was to give underwright the
contract was given verbally on a zoom
call with NK Management on the 7th of
May by the then director General and he
described this as significant point at
the center of this
Audi had tried to portray the guarantees
the decision given late in the
negotiations on the zoom call by g4bs
whether the awareness of the executive
board
clearly this is not correct the decision
was taken early by orchi and known
widely within the executive board in RTE
so let me move to the invoicing
arrangements for a Renault contract
our document pack shows that OT did not
just suggest the idea of the contract
with Renault it oversaw every
development and implementation of same
we were happy with that we knew Rana was
a major major sponsor for RTE so orti
would be committed to keeping them happy
we knew the contract with Renault was a
separate contract from Ryan's
independent contractor Services Ryan had
for
OT for radio and TV work
we understood that Ryan would have to do
extra work for Renault but that was no
difference to the other work that Ryan
would do for the BBC or with his
Publishers Etc this was just a separate
commercial agreement
Ryan was agreeing to a substantial pay
cut for more tea and he was entitled to
seek all the work outside of 48. there
was nothing secret about this nothing
secret about this far from us the
contract required runs to public
appearances for Renault which they could
seek and expect attention and indeed
they did
so with the terms agreed already
instructors had to invoice for this work
for the first invoice the instructions
to raise an invoice directly with
Renault and they gave us names and
details said on the proposed narrative
for the invoice as you can see the
instructions OT gave us
for this is an email on the 24th of July
2020 page 23 in this pack and on page 24
you can see the invoice we did indeed
sent to Renault when it came to invoices
for two and three Ortega's new
instructions I refer to to page 25 of
the pack
this is an email from the den commercial
director Geraldine O'Leary dated the
29th of April 2022 this invoice passed
on instructions as for how invoices two
and three should be raised and the email
Strokes us on the company name to be put
on the invoice asked us the address to
be put on the invoice the vat reference
to be included in the invoice and it
instructs us not to put any person's
name
this email also gathers General
Insurance from a colleague of the cities
that said if he meaning NK management
sends it back to me I will sort
everything else out
you should know that while invoices were
made that to asked us we were directed
by to email them to RTE they would do
what was necessary to process them with
us I should stress that at this time we
in NK management had no idea who asked
this was we had no reason to think that
Asus was linked to RTE or that it was
acting on behalf of RTE with no idea
they might be making payments
to us on behalf of RTE or that the
payments were linked to OT underwriting
the Renault contract
or she never said that to us asked us
never said that to us and Renault never
said that to us we simply followed
instructions we were given as we had
with the first invoice you will see a
copy of the two invoices raised in the
name vast has been sent by email from Mr
orti and the pack of pages 2627.
people have asked us why we went along
with those instructions why we didn't
set out more detail about what the
invoice is related to
time we had no reason to suspect that
our team might be trying to hide
payments to rhyme and I'm still shocked
that that was their intention we trusted
RTE
it's not someone known startup
with opaque funding and checkered past
or a record for dodgy Financial dealings
it's a National Institution
100 years old massive business turning
over 350 million a year
it has internal and external Auditors it
has a heavyweight board teams of
financial advisors accountants
as Mr Becker suggesting Ortega's robust
processes and rigors oversight of
Financial in many parts of the
organization
and that is what we assumed too
why would we suspect that there were
hiding information about one of their
key contracts why would they even do
that why would they even do that
I'm sorry but it's importance
but I want to address one other thing
there's been a lot of coverage of a side
letter with the 2020 contract in which
the director General says the agreed
earnings in the contract won't be
reduced during the term of the contract
as any lawyer will confirm
this letter no practical impact the
contract itself guarantees the earnings
and that is what a contract does we were
simply trying to impress an RTE
that Ryan had just signed up to new cuts
in his 2020 contract of 525 000.
and it also never taken the payment of
120 000
so they shouldn't even think about
coming back for more quotes given the
size of those cuts and to conclude
ladies and gentlemen
for the past number of years Ryan has
continued to perform at the highest
level
working with millions of colleagues
and leading shows which bring in
over the six year periods 100 million in
Revenue to RTA
he raised tens of Millions for Charities
through the Toy Show various Appeals
we've heard a lot about Ortiz Public
Service ethos a lot about the public
service influence but that's called a
space
OT is a hybrid organization
as commercial activities are key to
keeping the station afloat
maintaining jobs
and creating content
Ryan property has been a huge driver for
most for Ortiz's most successful
commercial activity cities over the past
14 years
Ryan and I have attracted
and our families and our friends
are horrendous horrendous amount of
criticism and abuse in the past few
weeks and I would not wish it on anybody
why
because the only figure in this whole
story whose face was recognizable was
Ryan property
he's been made a poster boy for this
scandal
and that's undeserved this is not the
Ryan Tubidy scandal
this is the RTE Scandal thanks thank you
thank you
um just before we thanks for those
opening statements just before we moved
to the committee members
um just uh there's one issue Mr Mr
strawberry you might clarify for me uh
the issue of the 75 000 payments
obviously the invoices for that was what
brought us late in March when the
Auditors found him and when I first
heard about this and I wanted to ask you
this this morning just to set the scene
for this meeting that uh those that 75
000 shortfall Gap that had to be made up
kind of what should I additional payment
the country will shut down uh thousands
of my constituents and people around the
country were on two or three hundred
euros a week pandemic payment
and you and your agent you know between
you did you have any doubts about the
merits of that or The credibility of
looking you know to make up that 75 000
at that particular point you know
because you run The Late Late Show and
very provided a good service you know
and I watched it because you know it's
scorpion it right throughout took over
and to just acknowledge that the
performance is Regret uh given the
circumstances but did you have any
doubts about you know the credibility or
the merits of that of looking for that
and your own credibility I appreciate
the question and the kind of short
answers I I I think what I'm going to be
saying a lot today
which is in relation to that is that is
that my my agent and friend Noel Kelly
it's his job to
get the best deal as he sees it for his
clients are your instructions well you
could say that yeah of course he would
absolutely try and get them what he
considers to be the best dealers if any
doubts endorse discussions discussions
between you back in the earlier
I think it would be fair to say
in terms of the the
financial implications of the commercial
side of RTE that it probably felt it
wasn't problematic in that sense that's
not what I'll ask you did you have
doubts about the public Optics of this
and the possible reputational damage of
looking for that 75 000 indoor
circumstances yes or no and did you
discuss that Emirates of that that's all
I want to know I would say that I would
always have doubts about doing too much
and did you just push that with your
agent do we have a conversation about
that no it's unlikely no no so you're no
country you're telling me you're smart
and actually no conversation with NK
Communications regarding the matter of
looking for discount for 75 000 no we
wouldn't we we would be inclined to just
I my my to be honest with you care like
I say to Noel I say you do your job and
I do mine right that's how it works but
you knew that you knew that this Gap had
to be made up into 75 000 had to be
a magic dog somewhere another point of a
veteran I trust in the process yes so
you have terrified at you no doubts but
demerits The credibility or the possible
reputational damage that was the
discourse that was not discussed okay
thank you thank you Deputy Melton once
for 15 minutes
uh good morning to our guests all right
Witnesses rather
um I just want to start off with the
tripartite agreement Mr Kelly
um just in relation to that
can you and I'd ask you to keep your
answers as short as possible can you
tell us briefly how did that actually
come about what was the reason for it
I just refer to someone else
um
how it came about it was a an OT
initiative RTA Reynolds budget yeah okay
sorry just for a second it was an RTE
initiative but I had to stem from
somewhere you said in your opening
statement that Ryan was agreeing to a
substantial pay cut for more to e so was
it did it come about on the basis of you
negotiating with RTE so how did it come
about
um or Ryan's contractors for 205 radio
shows
um and it's for 38 to our TV shows this
was a comedy separate agreement and it
came about
um because Renault and RTE wanted Ryan
to do more work around the sponsorship
wanted them to do late late shows and in
dealers Etc so that's where it came from
so it's you're saying you're seriously
saying that it didn't come about at all
from the pay cuts that
the sponsor wants us to do activity to
embellish the sponsorship around the
dealers but why would RTE
of their own bat be concerned about
setting your client up with a commercial
deal why would they why would they
suddenly when at a time when everybody
else was asked to take pay cuts why
would RTE and who in RTE came to you and
said listen we want to look after Ryan
we want to set up a separate commercial
deal
can you honestly say that you did not
initiate that in any shape or form
Authority whatsoever right so tell us
then who in order to e came to you and
what did they say
um
if we're referred to a page five in the
pack
[Applause]
under the contract
to check proposed terms of the new
contract this came from Fredo Keith and
was a couple other people as well so
they wanted Ryan and Renault had wanted
Ryan to do uh to go to the dealers to
you know to meet all of their customers
the relationship with the sponsor is
with RTA we've nothing to do with that
like no I I I we don't work with Renault
I don't you know so the relationship is
with RTE and the relationship is it's
it's probably the biggest sponsorship so
RTE contacted you and said listen we're
a little bit concerned Ryan has taken a
pay cut
this is nothing about pay cuts this is
the whole thing about it okay this was a
separate a separate commercial deal that
but who who initiate who came to you was
it the director General came to you no
uh breed O'Keefe breed or Keith came to
see in page nine of your documents the
pack that you gave us
um it says
we would also need and this came from
yourself I think we would also need a
side letter agreement from or to e to
guarantee and underwrite this fee for
the duration of the contract and Beyond
into the next
contract so you thought it guarantee for
a deal that you'd nothing really to do
it do it so why why I was looking for a
guarantee it's quite simple it was never
forward to you to pay it it was that if
the sponsor changes so we we have a
five-year contract with the RTE for
so radio shows yeah
sorry time is of the essence but you
sought the guarantee
that RTE would pay if the deal went
belly up it was never 40 to pay the
guarantee was around if another sponsor
came in that we they would have so that
again the relationship is with OT and
the sponsor not with us so they'd have
to talk to the sponsor says do you want
them you know would you like them to do
like the sponsor obviously wants to have
um the hosts performance
you didn't agree with RTE underwriting
the deal it wasn't about from the
writing it was about a Sponsor Change
was actually but at this stage the
sponsors were gone
no Reynold just I'm talking about the
tripart I'm talking about years two and
three as well right yes not only did RTE
underwrite the Renault contract but they
also there was an agreement there to
underwrite the two and you were looking
for a side letter agreement or more to
eat a guarantee and underwrite this for
the duration of this contract and Beyond
into the next contracts you clearly
there's that page nine year documents
you wanted RTE to underwrite and in
response to you
uh reader O'Keefe I think it's uh her
email on page 10 of your pack um she
said on behalf of 40e
um
States explicitly that we can provide
you with a side letter to underwrite
this fee for duration of contract
right so you'd requested that they
underwrite it and she in that email in
page 10 of the pack was responding to
your request
that's correct
yes yes yes yeah so what what so I I
mean
there's one thing about and you said uh
that Ryan was um agreeing to substantial
pay cut and he was entitled to seek work
elsewhere and that's that's absolutely
fine nobody has an issue with this but
the problem here is
that the deal was underwritten at your
request
for the three years
at your request by the public purse no
that's that's the problem here okay the
deal was underwritten at your request
for the three years of the contract and
it was paid for by public monies that's
the issue
um
I asked for the deal to be underwritten
because the relationship the sponsor is
underwritten by who
RTE yeah yeah the public course yeah but
but the spawn it's actually about the
sponsorship we I just want no Look in
relation in relationship
and that could only mean that RTE take
the head for it and they Pony up I just
want to move on because time is up here
you refer to page 25 in the packets page
six in your statement there was an email
from the commercial director for the two
by three invoices for 75 and it was very
uh should be raised and there was an
instruction not to put any person's name
on it
and you said there was no secret about
this deal but you agreed to
not putting a name on that I mean
did you I presume you'll agree that
there was no consultancy fees that there
was no consultancy done for 75 000 years
out what no no what we did was act on at
all times instructions from RTA and as I
said RTA is 100 year old organization
with
Auditors accountants
you're a businessman you're a negotiator
you look after your clients that's your
job that's your job there's no issue
with that whatsoever but you'd imagine
when you were instructed not to put
names on the invoices and we're not
talking about 299 or 350 three or 50
cents we're talking about invoices for
75 000 and you knowing that you had
ask them to underwrite the agreement
so you had asked them that they
underwrite they confirmed that they were
underwriting agreement they were putting
it through the barter account you were
told not to put a name on it you knew
exactly what it was for
and you didn't flag that up you went
along with it and yet you say there was
nothing secret about the deal there was
nothing secrets we simply acted under
instructions from RTE yeah yeah but you
knew they were underwriting the deal and
you knew that was the 75
000 payments that was due to to Mr
tuberty we said you didn't but I said we
simply acted on the instructions for
more to you so that's yeah fair enough
that
um
we had heard last week that the the
Auditors weren't happy that grand
Taunton abroad were brought in and that
um at some point you were informed of it
uh
when was that and was it the director
General that informed you or who or when
that was May
um
that was May 23rd of this year 23rd and
that would have been from Ortiz
um Legal Office
the legal office which would have been
who exactly
from from somebody from Ortiz Legal
Office
sorry
26. yeah
[Applause]
thank you okay so that was from Paula
miloli director of legal Affairs and
that was the 26th of May 2023 okay and
so
RTE new grand torrent and new new
digital you're client about it yes we
would have informed our clients of
course but that was the first that we
had heard yeah
yeah I just want to come to Mr tuberty
if I can please
and there's just um in 2019 you might
have seen this out in the public domain
recently that you were launching the
Saint Vincent De Paul
um Christmas appeal and when you're
interviewed you were said that you were
haunted by um the idea of children in
poverty and the homeless crisis and he
also said that you'd accept
or to ease cost-cutting measures
gracefully and when it comes to this
sort of issue that's not something
you've ever been found wanting on but
here we are three or four years later
and we know that that pay cut was
subsidized by this deal
yeah I wouldn't characterize that as a a
breakup being subsidized by any deal I
also I also but that's that's what it is
with respect to Deputy I would also uh
urge you not to conflate
somebody being well paid with somebody
who might not have a conscience
particularly with work uh that you know
that you mentioned Saint Vincent De Paul
it's a charity I have enormous time for
since
I'm sure sorry just one second we're
asking I appreciate that but just just I
just think it's no there's no
circumstances
I'm referring to what you stated sorry
you're quoted in the media yes that's
what I'm referring okay and I accept
that you do a lot of charity work no I'm
not trying to say that I'm not sure
otherwise
yeah I understand you do that good work
um but at the same time you knew that
this separate deal was been done and it
would compensate for the pay cuts but
you also knew and this is the thing that
your agent had requested that RTE
underwrite that agreement
so you knew that
that paid here was going to make softer
or not even in enhance any pay cut that
had been taken but she also knew from
through your agent that RTE were
underwriting that deal so that you knew
that when you're coming misunderstanding
here honestly honestly this was a
separate
conflicts for separate Services
separate contracts for separate services
this had nothing to do with Ryan's new
contract for radio and TV service this
is a separate contract that's what I'm
talking about the tripartite deal yeah
where the two with Aussie
yeah yeah had underwritten that
agreement yes and they were paying it
and my question to Mr tupperton sorry
run over pain Renault but RTE paid them
and then the 27. if
OT paid them that was an RTE thing
Renault paid Reno paid yeah
that was yeah that was absolutely
nothing to do unless we don't work for I
don't work for RTA we don't work 40 so
no just uh absolutely
I'm talking about the two that we've
just discussed it's here there's no way
you don't know about it the two 75 000
Euro payments and that were put through
that you were asked not to put a name
not to put any person's name on again
the question we interacted with Mr
tuberty Mr Toby Mr Kelly please
I think the reason sorry to clarify
there isn't null is is coming in on this
is because his knowledge of the nuts and
bolts of these things is far superior to
mine so I've not been disrespectful
likewise but I'm asking you again yes in
relation to that when you know and you
did yeah say that you know it it haunts
you and child poverty and that and yes
that's perfect of course of course you
do yeah but I'm saying where does that
tally with the fact that
you knew that the two payments that were
going through for 75 000 the tripart
agreement was struck right you knew that
they were for yourself as part of that
tripart agreement which you would have
also known that RTE had agreed to
underwrite that agreement so in fact it
was the taxpayers it was the license
feeholders that were paying that money
because I understand
there was a relationship with Renault
that would sort that out no the second
and third one we're talking about were I
mean yeah but am I not right
there seems to be a misunderstanding
there's no absolutely sat through three
weeks of it in all fairness Mr Tommy
because I hope this understanding from
ourselves I'm talking about the 275.
look if you do what if you prefer not to
answer that's fine if you don't want to
answer no I'm happy to answer I just I
just feel that I was always under the
impression that money was not was from
Red I wasn't ready yes you received
three
845 000. extra in payments now it was
underwritten by RTE for the taxpayer I I
I I I I I really dispute that okay so
we're going to move on because
we have full attendance here uh Deputy
thank you ten minutes
thanks very much chairperson and and
thank you
um to the witnesses for attending and
for your opening statements I know Mr
tuberty you're fond of a small quirky
fact that tells a story
um and I'm sure as well you know 79 of
us listen to radio daily
here in Ireland uh despite everything
else that's open to us from Spotify to
podcasts to everything else
we're like most people who are big radio
listeners in in our house and you were
in our kitchen flight mornings a week
um
and I think that's the thing I think
it's
you were that familiar voice in your
attention you know
when you told us we're all in it
together during covert in particular and
during the recessions
we believed you
and I think that's why we we feel so
Shattered by this story now you said a
very strong rebuttal here
it's cleared at RTE when they appear
before us again on Thursday are going to
have very serious set of questions that
they have to answer
well the fact remains public trust in a
public broadcaster and in you for writer
for round
has been shattered
um
and that has to be rebuilt and maybe
today is the start and and we'll see
um I wanted to ask you just very quick
question did you engage the services to
the tree you engage the service of
Crisis comms team before appearing today
either intern or extern we we had we did
assemble a team of people to talk to to
talk with and to get the best advice I
was always told that by relative Minds
that always surround yourself for people
smarter than you so yeah of course you
spoke to people yeah or people in pay in
order to offer crisis comments either
intern or external I presume they
weren't doing it for for free of course
okay I'm going to take that as yes
um I hope the answer to this is no but
were you advised by those people to
delay to the documentation until no no
no the documentation and I I am my
apologies for that I think
the it's a very it's very comprehensive
set of documentation it sheds a lot of
love do you want me to come back but it
was to receive it at half age yeah and I
think particularly if the staff who
support this committee who stayed up
until very late my apologies you want me
to come back another word keep going
okay I'm trying
the last three weeks have been chaotic
they have been destructive they have
been
Beyond difficult
And all I'll say to you is that we
wanted to get things right today because
so many people have been getting things
wrong okay I fully accept I don't want
to interruptions
we were working on this until the mid
burn in the midnight also yeah I just
want to examine one thing that's in your
opening statement this morning you stay
clearly that you took a 20 pay cut and
is that inclusive or exclusive of the 75
000 Euro that you're receiving either
from Renault or true RTE true about
account when you say you took 20 pay cut
is that inclusive or exclusive of the 75
and it'll take that if I can understand
thank you and the 20 was Ryan's contract
was 495-495-545-545545
[Music]
so that was from 15 to 19 and in Ryan's
then next contract his salary was 440
000 per annum which was 200 000 for
radio 240 000 for TV that was 105 000
reduction per year by five so that was
525 000 it didn't include the 120 000
that he didn't take and the Renault 75
000 was a completely separate contract
so this was on his TV and radio earnings
so it's exclusive of the Renault
contract or the payment true yeah no I I
just have to contest that we we regard
this as separate now the the email over
and back that we see in the contract
negotiations are shocking to I think all
of the members for a number of reasons
one being the number of people who are
actually included and you've drawn
attention to that yes but it also points
very clearly to the fact that actually
it's not separation it is part of the
original economy no it's not project
within I mean if it was entirely
separate then plywood or to even so
or she came to us with this
like at all times everything to do with
this contract was under construction for
Morty but it was the the contract was
and the payments were with kind of the
sponsor and that was still the sponsor
of The Late Late Show I I asked a
question Mr strawberry and it wasn't
your opening statement so that's
exclusive of the 75 000 would you accept
that it's difficult for us to reconcile
the idea that there's an entirely
separate Arrangement when it Formed part
of the contract negotiation yeah I
understand where you're coming from
entirely but yeah okay so I understand
the room for for perception issues yes
okay
um Mr Kelly I just want to move on to
your part in this I want to ask briefly
because I think it's important that we
put to bed the idea that Mr tubbery made
any decision Around The Late Late
uh on foot off
we know that the two problematic
invoices were presented to deforbs on
the 8th of March and we know that Mr
cupboardy announced his decision whether
whenever he took his decision he
announced it on the 16th of March
um would you have deforest's number in
your phone no no I I if I can explain
I've met three Forbes I would say and
this is like it's it's there's so many
unsuits and so many stuff like and I'm
finding bizarre so I I've only ever met
G-Force with her legal team and with her
and her lawyers in their office in RTA I
have never had a cup of tea or tea
Forbes I've never met defaults for lunch
I've never had it for dinner I don't
know deforms apart from when I'd meet
her in the order
and it we're so time competing I think
if you if you have a question with
regard to the departure of The Late Late
Show that was so deeply personal and so
deeply and from my heart I would urge
you to ask me about that I want to ask a
very simple question and it sounds like
you've welcomed the opportunity was
there any communication
to either your assessment Mr company or
to know calorie management between the
8th and the 16th of March with regard to
these problematic invoices
that's fine the first indication was on
the 23rd of May well now I do want to
contest that because on the 3rd of May
there is an over and back a third and
the fifth sorry sorry
um
sorry uh NK management where
specific references made to the CMS
invoices yeah and I do want to ask about
the decision to use CMS so I do want to
contest that because there's certainly
an over and back between Management on
the third of May because there's just a
lot of emails on the 3rd of May
um was the first time that we were made
aware of it and then after that we met
with Grant Thornton to talk to them
about it so in relation to Ryan stepping
down and stepping back
Ryan had said it to me the previous year
and I was I said to him why why are you
leaving
yeah I needed so I so did my family they
thought it was mad and to be honest with
you
a very good friend of hers online I said
fine why are you leaving stay on the
Lakeland it's a brilliant it's a great
show you know
and I knew after code when you're
playing to no audience when you're
thought it was a really difficult show
to do
I'm so sorry
I know I have two minutes remaining and
a list of questions anyway we we'd been
aware of this for quite a while and I
was trying to get him to stay okay
I want to ask you about this so This
invoicing of asked us and I do notice in
in the accounts that are returned at the
end of the year that money transferred
to Total Productions is
you can see it essentially in a normal
run of the year the the amount of money
derived from Noel Kelly management is
quite small in the years in question
it's it's large you can see the 75 000
left
um you have I think four companies that
which are registered at a unit B2 and
the government office Park and
Parliament so Noel Kelly management no
College management nominees limited
which is registered 16 to March this
year Century Merchandising Services
clearly consultancy limited why was it
CMS
doc decided to raise the invoice because
I have two companies which is NK
management and CMS and we were asked to
send the invoice in from CMS by RTE
why why CMS that was their instructions
it's no Kelly management that appears at
the end of year sure sure but CMS is we
own CMS as well it's a sister company
management above CMS it just adds a
layer sure because Noel Kelly management
I know who's that who yeah it is CMS I
don't yeah again we were directed by
orta with this direction from RT
um
and we've all received emails in saying
you know just uh all you have to do is
invoice a certain company in wherever
and all this money will be yours this
idea of
invoice for 75 000 to it a company you
say you don't know you've never come
across
um
you've no reason to suspect RTE or
hiding payments but they said can you
can you invoice this company in order to
receive a payment and you didn't say I'm
sorry but who is this company and why am
I invoicing them
sure
RTA
it has its say 1800 employees twins over
350 million years we're a small little
company there's there's eight of us
we were asked under instruction to do
this and that's what we did
yeah
briefly am I alert just very briefly
just to the deputy uh regarding your
listener
excuse me you're listening to my radio
show like during the week
um I miss this unfortunately I'm up here
sorry you're a white record sorry or
your partner
um well thank you for for that and and
I'm sorry to hear that that
um she feels that way about the program
but I can assure you this is what today
is all about
is rebuilding that trust that may have
may have been undermined by a lot of
misunderstanding
thank you very much and thank you both
for coming in here voluntary very much
appreciate it can I just follow up on my
colleague there uh Century Merchandising
Services Limited is CMS and since
but when I've done my company officers I
found all the CMS companies have been
struck off so I'm I'm a bit concerned
about you using that when the company's
office showed at all the CMS companies
have been struck off to register so
you're it's trading under
Century Merchandising Services not CMS
okay CMS is just the yeah I know but
it's just from the clarification CMS all
the companies that are registered on the
right name have been struck out for
various reasons can I just ask a
question in relation to the contracts
the contracts between RT and
um total Productions limited that's the
agreement The Five-Year agreement yes
but the agreement then between uh which
is draft of yourselves is between
is there a reason for that
so the rental contracts
um
sorry on page five and I have a copy of
the agreement here that and it shows
this is the agreement that was
um that was prepared in relation to the
agreement between the three
organizations yes but it starts with
total Productions so the agreement is
was written by RTE legal no no this is
the one that I've got which is oh sorry
for the services for the services yeah
so with the services we had numerous
meetings with Renault in relation to the
actual activity itself
um and I think part of the confusion is
the the events were for 20 21 22. but
the agreement is in is in a separate
legal entity to the agreement between
total Productions limited and RCA yes
it's a disagreement is between right
charity
Renault and RT sure well sorry Ryan
probably been total okay but can I just
ask then enrich to 75 000 does that go
into the total Productions account yes
okay because the invoice then when you
the invoice that was produced
um
read invoice and then then
the invoice doesn't mention total
Productions in the invoice that you
produce it mentions right property it
doesn't mention Turtles it doesn't
wrench in Turtle at all
so we were directed Again by OT ort
legal to put down Ryan toy review spoke
partnership between randomly included
but if the agreement is ongoing which uh
total Productions why then send out the
invoice in this in as a person's name
rather than the the agreement was is
with
Renault RTE the invoicing and another
right is the service provider we invoice
on behalf of Brian and then from a legal
point of view what I'm saying to you is
that there seems to be two different
legal entities one total Productions the
other one right over no there's really
showed us so no that's the render on the
range of the invoice that there's only
total Productions which is why in
trouble this company okay all right can
I then go on to in relation to the
invoices itself
um when you saw who that you were making
out to an English company or a company
based in the UK did you not raise
serious concerns under this issue
because obviously if it's made out to a
UK company you you're then not putting
in for a PhD or anything else yet the
service was delivered in Ireland
we um again under construction from RTE
we wondered you're a separate legal
entity
has have asked uh further questions on
that we sent the invoices into RTE
yeah but when you were asked to send in
the invoices you were asked to make out
the invoices when you know you were
asked me come out for a UK company did
it not raise concerns from your point of
view as regards you know to make sure
that you were not doing anything which
was
um you know where the service in
particular where the service was
delivered here in Ireland the service
wasn't delivered in the UK sure it was
delivered to RT to Reno yeah and not
um and not to a UK company well we knew
that the contract was that ran out and
it was a separate contract for
independent contractor Services everyone
had to do the work Authority and we
understood that Ryan would have 2X to
work but Grano but there was no
difference
that the deputy is trying to ask you
David you just put that question
straight again because it's a very
direct question
you know when the invoice was made out
it was made out to a UK company what I'm
saying is that the service was delivered
in Ireland yeah far Irish companies
basically RTE and Renault we're here in
Ireland who did that not raise concerns
which he wrote from an accounting point
of view of yourselves that you were
being asked now to build a UK company
you're saying you're statement that you
knew nothing about the Barger account
you never dealt with a barber account
before this is the first time dealing
with it there's not did you not raise
questions as to why you should make it
out to a UK company okay well if I could
just in relation to that uh at the time
we didn't know who uh had more reason
for raising the question no if you
didn't know about it but we presumed
that the relationship with Renault and
we followed the instructions exactly and
subsequently did you raise that question
will it run out to know was it was this
the reason why was this the connection
rather than sending in remember to zorti
will give you the instructions that we
know therefore should you not have
raised that question
but again we didn't raise the question
we didn't raise the question because it
was under instruction from RTE
okay can I just ask in relation to
um Paige in the grand Torrington report
um a paragraph 22g it raises the fact
about that uh the director General was
not involved in dealing signing or
implementation of disagreement being the
tripartite agreement
was there because this seems to be we're
being furnished certain names but we're
not being given all the names and I'm
just wondering who exactly was there
that knew about all of this agreement
sorry so okay we were involved there but
who from RT was there that was involved
in disagreement so
um from legal Trish wheeler from Finance
burrito Keith C and the CEO
um deforbs and then somebody on the exec
the grand Taunton report says the direct
return was not involved in the drafting
signing or implementation of the screen
oh sorry the draft and sign
implementation was would have been
um legal and finance and and commercial
but can you tell us who was there from
Legal Financial and Commercial
so
okay sorry it was the orchard
solicitor's office
but no no but you're saying the
commercial people were there as well but
who who we need to know who exactly was
there because this information has been
given to us
you were there someone from your office
page page 14.
[Applause]
so you had uh myself
um
Neve breed O'Keefe and Katrina Falcon
from the ort solicitor's office sorry
who am I apologies sir
uh Katrina Faulkner from the solicitors
office yeah was there anyone else there
um Trish Williams from solicitor's
office as well okay all right okay can I
just move on there
um to run trouble to yourself and
strawberry can I just ask you know this
whole issue and my colleague raised it
about you know the the level of fees and
think when I looked at your account
servers uh in 2016 the income through
the accounts was 660 000 and I accept
that there has been a reduction in what
you're receiving but all of this
controversy you know there's no whole
problem within I suppose the entire
country but also within RT about the
whole issue of trust the holy issue of
the ethics of this I mean looking at it
now how do you feel that the trust can
be built up back up and the second thing
is about your own
um preference at this stage about going
back working for RT yeah but your own oh
I don't have any doubt I want to go back
to work on the radio as soon as possible
um I think that I don't say that with
any arrogance I just say they've
expressed desires what I do it's it's
what I know and and I want to get back
to my team and and to the listeners and
and do my job one issue in relation to
trust no I I I understand that Debbie
down and I will say that I I understand
the the amount of money we're talking
about is is is is eye watering I I like
I'm not a fool I understand that but I
haven't changed as a person over the
over those years because despite the
extraordinary question and ask you is
how would you now rebuild that trust
well a lot of the trust was taken from
me
I I will just say I think that they're
off to a good start this week with the
new director General I think that
they're going to be uh I think that
hopefully people will see what I've said
today and we'll we'll hear what I'm
saying today and they'll realize that a
lot of what's happened over the last
three weeks I've been dragged into a
mess not of my own making mutual
colleagues Deputy with my colleagues the
only thing I have for my colleagues is
respect Deputy Devlin
thank you very much to our Witnesses uh
for your attendance this morning and can
I say at the outset um you know the such
is the issue surrounding this uh that
you're right about uh people stopping
you obviously we're living in the same
area and I know uh the high regard in
which you're held and the respect people
have for you including kids
who are wondering why the toy man is
being in the news so much uh that said
uh obviously I wonder given the events
of the last two weeks and we've engaged
with RTE on quite a number of times
um has that been the reason why you
wanted to come here voluntarily or was
it actually more of what you heard from
those engagements with orti and what
they've said the various Executives and
board members or has it been that
everything else surrounding this whole
issue what's the main driver if you
wanted to I think that my name has been
desperately solid
I think my reputation has been solid
I'm deeply upset
I'm hurt
I am in I'm it's hard to leave the house
if you really want me to be honest about
it
um
so for what
I spent three weeks watching people
telling stories
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm leaving a gap
I'm forgive me it's a comma not a full
stop
but
I know like I'm not looking for sympathy
now or or violin I'm simply saying to
you right you asked me the question and
you bring up like the kids my
relationship with the children of
Ireland is so important to me I know
that sounds grandiose but actually it is
I want them to be happy and hopeful and
proud to be Irish and read lots of books
and just be wonderful young people you
know that that doesn't change you know
but what's happened in the last three
weeks
can I specifically ask you then in terms
of what you've heard and maybe to Mr
Kelly as well on this uh all of the
evidence and I presume you watched all
of the evidence that's been given to
both Iraqis committees over the last
couple of weeks uh you know even in uh
Mr tuberty's statement uh I think you
refer to it as a fog of confusion to me
it's a cloud of confusion at this point
because there's what you're saying now
contradicts directly contradicts what
this committee and others have been told
over uh the last couple of weeks by
certain individuals and that's extremely
worrying both from a parliamentary
perspective but also from a fact and
truthful perspective bearing in mind
referring to your own statement uh Mr
Kelly an institution of the Irish State
and those uh representing it can I just
turn to
um
kind of turned to a few elements one is
in terms of the
question around your decision uh Mr
tuberty and you you said that you had
been thinking about long and hard and
obviously I can appreciate why it would
be such a big decision yeah um but is
there any evidence uh and it's not that
I doubt your your decision or when you
make it you please don't but for clarity
in terms of the public domain yes is
there any correspondence predating uh
kind of the sky April May yeah between
the two of you just it's not that I want
to publish but I just want to clear the
record is there anything that his text
messages emails anything that's saying
look this is
sorry definitely
we asked to come here today we have to
come here today we weren't invited we
asked and we saw over the last three
weeks I've never seen such horrendous
horrendous reporting
and why certainly the most trusted man
in Ireland Ryan Toby it was like throw
him under a bus what why why when that
report came out the first report came
out that was sent out from the board on
the 22nd yeah this is a statement the
statement we had to ask our lawyers can
we get a copy because again we're on the
back foot when orchi said at the top 10
earners
again we get 10 minutes and again I had
to put in a request can we please have
the information and again so so we we
got we got the statement and when we got
the statement half an hour before it
went out we said there's an accuracies
in this and Grand Porter said there's no
wrong building on we have foreign
we asked them to put it in and they
didn't four days later it was sorry if I
could just answer four days later it was
it was put in right and four days later
Ryan Toby was taken off the air he
didn't have a show on Friday he wasn't
on the show the following week it looked
like it was complicit in this whole
so
I'm sorry we we have
this has been this has been the worst of
times the worst of time no I appreciate
that and I know that's why you're here
I'd like to add we people have families
yeah just think people need to think
about I mean you got you're a public
representative you know what it means
when you're in the middle of something
you get that I'm not this is my first
rodeo being in the public eye but I've
never seen nothing like it I I don't
know if any of you've been canceled
before but let me tell you you don't
want to be there so just so just in
terms of okay so connect and we can talk
about that later then just in terms of
in terms of the I suppose the statements
that have been made both the physical
statements and indeed the oral
statements that are made in the house of
the rockness uh you've alluded to
um one of the inaccuracies uh Mr Tubidy
you say about the secretly overpay
overpayment by RTE which you said which
he challenged back in 2020 was that in
writing that challenge wasn't we have
this we have to it's in your documents
yeah okay if it's in your documents
because there's a lot of documents
listen I do appreciated
but that's why I've been working on this
so long
can I also okay can I just also get a
time frame then in terms of uh the
negotiation of uh Mr tuberty's first
contract uh did that started probably in
2014 was it sorry for the 15 contract
would have started
probably end of 14 yeah and then and
that round to 2020 and then there was
fresh negotiations around that okay when
did the negotiation start for the
Renault contract
which would run parallel with the 2020
contract so it would have started
probably late 19th you can see where you
can see where the confusion then or The
Cloud of confusion or what a fog of
confusion
arises when people say well the two of
them are running parallel to each other
and one has a 20 pay cut and the other
one has a shirt okay so can I just
answer please please because I'm under
time pressure I know but you ask me a
question
um
within that within that time frame very
simply
um we had as I said we had agreed too
that 120 gone we'd agree to 505 000 not
to be invoiced
um
we didn't we didn't work printing that
and I appreciate what you're saying in a
fog like
there's so much confusion that I like I
if I said it when we're sitting yeah no
I mean if you're finding your your
computer
can I just also say to you in terms of
the invoicing I hear what you say you
you did what you were told yes there was
an email there in the pack that you
provided saying also mention all this
information on the invoice uh now astus
I think is the name of the company that
you're told to invoice from
um did you ever meet any representative
from Masters no is this just a new
company that you were told to invoice
this was a company return and that
wasn't really questioned at all on your
part though either no so so if RTE asked
you to pay
you know News Talk would you have done
that too I mean that's the question
where is it I'm being facetious because
I'm just asking all of a sudden a new
company you're a negotiating Authority
on a contract you're told to pay you're
told to invoice a different company
you've never heard of where did that
come about and how come there's no
questions that that that came that came
for more to you I know I get that but
why wasn't there a question about who am
I invoicing you know I'm negotiating
with RTE and now I'm invoicing Joe blogs
I I worked person Authority for 23 years
I'd never have questions working with
them do they ever ask you to invoice a
company you never heard of we had we had
never drawn a Roadshow like this before
no no but so there's something new
negotiations so we I I assumed that it
was a it was it was Renault okay and in
terms of that Zoom call then so the 7th
of May right see Forbes and OT lowers
okay and so were they the solicitors
that you're talking about the church
wheeling and so there was three three
representatives from RTE two from the
solicitor's office and the DG sorry that
there was there was one from the
services office the DG and myself and
then a colleague of mine a colleague of
yours it was on your side okay and I
kind of just asked then in terms of um
just in the last minute or so I have
in terms of the Toy Show the musical
because we've heard a lot about this and
we've heard there was a 2.2 million loss
now I know it's not your Mr Cutty I know
you're not directly involved uh but
you're an agent obviously on behalf of
Mr strawberry but Mr Tubidy obviously
worked with or works with RTE
well can I can I ask this though where
there are staff members from the toys
from The Late Late uh show and seconded
to the musical uh be a production staff
uh other Personnel from RTE directly
working on Toy Show the musical the toy
shows like Toy Show the musical was
something I had nothing to do with so
it's aware of anybody I think it's only
fair to say that you should put those
questions too about that because in
France like I I that's not that was not
my I'm not aware of any staff that were
conscious to from RTE to the Toy Story
there might have been people working in
parallel but second is probably too
strong a word okay okay and then just in
the last couple of seconds can I just
ask probably Mr property given that
you're the faces was said earlier of of
this issue yeah that that's been
unfortunate yeah so in terms of
everything you've heard uh from uh your
former colleagues in in RTA directors
and Executives
um what has been the biggest inaccuracy
that you've heard that you say I know
you've highlighted seven but is there
any one in particular that you want to
highlight in on uh this afternoon I
think seven is quite enough
10 minutes
I'd like to welcome our Witnesses here
um this morning before that the
committee and hopefully this meeting
will go some way towards getting
transparency something that I I think
has been uh you know missing up until at
this point I just want to establish a a
timeline a clear timeline as to who knew
what and when
um so we know on on March the third Mr
Tubidy you had uh stated when questioned
um about your ongoing position with the
Late Late Show as to whether you will
continue or not you said I don't know
where this is coming from the story
comes up every year or two I am here
talking to you today with a view to go
straight back into the job I love so
that that that's correct you know I know
exactly what you're talking about in
fact I remember well that interview and
I can I can fill you in on all the
details you know there's no need to know
but that that's the third March the 7th
we know from questioning that uh the law
is first contacted Richard Collins the
Chief Financial Officer I think that has
been established it's it's not disputed
we know Mr Collins then on March the 8th
um contacted D Forbes
um to get to the bottom as to the nature
of of those two
um invoices that we know had been issued
that's not up for a dispute now it was
suggested
um or it was stated that amazing took
place uh between Mr Kelly and someone
within RTA at the weak beginning of of
the sixth March
um of this year would you do you recall
meeting someone no I I know I mean I
said the only meetings I had with uh
Miss Forbes were in the OT boardroom
with her and her lawyers and her
accountants and we had a zoom call that
was it okay did it was uh stated that
you met with Alan Tyler from RTA Do We
Begin the 6th of March no there's no way
thanks for that you've no no
recollection of that oh okay
um so can I ask Mr tuberty when did you
notify RTE that you are going sorry
sorry
I'll come back to you if you want to go
back to that question first sorry yeah
Alan Tyler the new head of entertainment
yep yes you met with him on what date I
would have met with them quite a few
times when he started in March what what
days
yeah I'm not really sure it's
just if you have your diary which may be
that you could just check that
uh just so you could or if you could
have somebody check it during the break
oh yeah I would reckon for 10 minutes
continue no I I I think it'd be
important that we establish when uh you
met with him in March once they did that
March the sixth and I I think it's
important in terms of the 13th
can I ask you what what you're what
sorry what is the question I I I'm just
wondering when he met with um
Mr tubby when did you inform more to you
you were stepping down well no on my
behalf of informed Dorothy on March the
13th that's right
okay
um on the same day you announced
publicly that you are going to be um
stepping back
from The Late Late Show no that was you
were talking about that interview that
that a few weeks before where I was at
an event
and do you want me to go into this or no
you stayed publicly I March sorry March
the 16th that that you were going to be
uh stepping back when did you notify
your RTA of your decision oh sorry
excuse me yeah my apologies the 13th
2016 to the public so can I ask had
anyone in RTE notified you Mr Tubidy are
you Mr Kelly no
the concerns that allow you to have okay
so I really I really must Deputy I have
to
because we can be here till the last yes
or no because time is of course yes or
no did anyone from RTA I needed a little
time to forgive me but I will be here
till the last dog barks until you
believe me that that decision came from
my heart and soul that started being
that decision the kernel of it was last
August okay so we can talk about
something yes
this was a very personal decision okay
so can you answer the question then did
anyone from RTA contact eight are you Mr
tuberty are you Mr Kelly about uh the
review that the lawyers had initiated
not till May not correct
yeah I was the one who went in can I ask
in terms of the Troy party agreement
um which was wasn't signed until the
21st of the Ford yeah uh 2023 yeah a
month after a month and a half after the
issue was was first girl I identified by
at that stage because the agreement
originally was supposed to be for 2020
the first first lot of events but then
that was covered then it went to 21 that
was covered so finally 22 we did the
first number of events
so as a result you know it wasn't signed
to the okay so so we're expected to
believe that it's purely coincidental
that a month and a half after the Laos
identified these you know questionable
invoices that you you take this down off
the shelf when everything had hit the
fan and you retrospectively uh sign us
um a couple of years after the the
contract had taken place and that's just
pure coincidental
if I could just answer yep
um the invoices were
um were sent to OT they sent them to ask
us
about this
agreement In fairness no Mr Kelly
um so it's purely coincidental that that
was taken down off the shelf and signed
in April
um a month and a half after uh delays
raised these concerns well the agreement
the three people in the agreement is
Renault
OTA
and we were a separate agreement just to
provide services
so just want to make that make that
clear okay so so the services were
turned away and it's actually more of uh
I suppose
you know it's an operational thing okay
so so you're leading us to believe it
was pure coincidence that that was
signed in uh April
um a month after the light raised these
issues and a number of years after the
the contract had been uh formed or come
about so can I talk in relation 18th of
April
um
page 35 in the pack
um Neil thank you for calling this
morning email below it's all I imagine
refers to the third side letter but she
dancing album fire we don't sit down
fully signed couple of Toronto and we
signed a lady the first Contact uh with
um so I've got the first one we were
concealing any issue it was just around
it was just around can I just ask in in
relation to uh the commercial contract
that you you say it was uh breed O'Keefe
who who came up with the uh the idea of
this uh forward first is that a normal
thing or would this be unusual in terms
of your uh to negotiating on behalf of
yeah to be honest I would I would uh
that's an RTA thing I I I don't know how
you know okay the people that you
represent would it be normal that RTE
would put forward proposals uh for a
commercial Island to be part of of uh
the contract would that be normal or an
exception it would be exceptional and
this is exceptional because Ryan as the
host of The Late Late Show andrena has a
sponsor of The Late Late Show The
Orchard and lately children owned by RTE
and it is it is yeah it's Unique no no
water cases
um
so in in in in relation to uh the
invoicing then
um
that we we know there was an attempt and
there's a trail there that no names were
to appear on the invoices uh whose uh
suggestion was it uh label them as a
consultancy phase
Portia RTA
who and RTE
informed you to put them down as a
consultancy phase
Geraldine O'Leary and
okay in the uh the grand Torrington uh
review it states very clearly that there
was no consultancy phase provided either
by the talent or the talents agents
um and it did not uh reflect the
substance of of the transactions actions
um can I ask you
um the Chief Financial Officer under
questioning last week when he asked in
in relation to these invoices
um the legality of them he stated that
it was in his view that the public had
been defrauded because uh of the
labeling of these invoices so you
clearly follow the instructions of
Geraldine O'Leary to
I would suggest purposely
um confuse the true nature of the
invoices and what was being built for
would you agree with the Chief Financial
Officer that the public has been
potentially defrauded because of of the
issuing of these invoices by yourself
and the payment priority of the 275 000.
at all times we were acting on
construction from RTA as we've already
stated
okay but would you um agree with the
Chief Financial Officer that uh the
taxpayer has been potentially defrauded
because
um there was no consultancy fees uh
provided
um
again this was it under instruction from
RTE okay
who issued the invoices
who issued the invoices towards he who
is the invoices we we sent invoice
Authority which RTE then you you issued
the invoices labeled consultancy fees
knowing that there was no consultancy
exactly so we acted under instructions
we can agree to uh but to spend briefly
for 10 minutes or even wait till we take
another speaker which specifically he
went through
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
which member of which is member of
saffron RT digital feedback during the
break it was amazing with Alan Tyler and
Jen Jennings who probably had a
programming content Alan Tyler is a head
of entertainment today okay yeah 6th of
March so we had a meeting the day at all
the devils the date yes yes yes 6th of
March sixth March okay thank you next
Committee Member is Deputy Verona Murphy
thank you chair I'm just in relation to
that meeting Mr Kelly was the topic
Grant Thornton brojo no thank you the
topic was
um
issues around uh I suppose it's worth
really achieved at The Late Late Show
timings on at the start during cover The
Late Late Show finished at 11 o'clock so
the issues were around and I don't mean
to cut off but you're you're just
categorically stating that there was
sorry sorry yes yes yes sorry sorry yeah
I know it was very much about issues
around the Late Night show and tried to
finish it earlier
Etc okay thank you
um
but it does seem a bit odd that she'd
been having that discussion given Mr
tuberty's
resignation or was it just for the
remaining shows no it was before it was
before and it wasn't it wasn't related
to it
um okay maybe you you want to talk first
no were you at that meeting yes I was
yeah okay
okay so it had nothing to do as you know
category I have no discussion Debbie
Murphy like I said at the statement of
the iPhone it was one of the the
untruths I really really wanted to clear
up here today and there was no no no
connection between this
Fiasco and my departure from The Late
Late Show I promise you so you'll have
watched all of the previous engagements
so is it your view Mr strawberry and
it's her like I don't know like look at
first started like to say you're welcome
here thank you very much it's nice that
you came without having to be compelled
thank you
it's not that anybody knows how to
address you because we're so everybody
feels they know you I know I prefer if
you come in mind
when you call me Deputy okay even all
that aside okay so perfect but the
reality is this you will have seen
Mr Adrian Lynch who is the
um interim director generally say that
it was possible that you did know for
your announcement yes that's very
unfortunate and do you feel is it your
review then that Mr Lynch threw you
under the bus with that connotation I Mr
Lynch is entitled to his conjecture but
in this case it's incorrect okay
well let me move to your statement
because you have outlined seven on
truths
and to be fair you've come here to give
your side to the story and we as
deputies need to hear both sides and
find the truth in between but I think
you have outlined in your statement
seven on truths and what I'd just like
to ask you is it your view
and maybe this is for Mr Kelly also but
is it your view that those aren't truths
were intended to deceive not just the
public
but the Public Accounts committee into
thinking that you two gentlemen were
responsible for everything that has
happened here I think we
being frank with you we were we watched
some of the proceedings quite aghast
but is it to review the thought
hope
that in in in in in in in a more
positive moment that that wasn't the
case that this is a misunderstanding
rather than intent to deceive I I would
hope but maybe no one has something
better to say about that
um
my Main Place could be as kind as Ryan
um and I think there were a lot of
misunderstandings I think as Ryan said
at the outset if everybody had just at
the start
and when we when we had to ask can we
get statements everybody just had sat
down and said what is that what is this
it's all that would have been explained
the 120 000 it was 120 000 and on and on
and on just in your case Mr Kelly at
some point Mr Collins was being asked
um in relation to why he did not ask
questions with regard to the invoices
being raised with consultancy fees as
the the uh description he said that
because and I don't want to miss quote
but sure the inclination the information
was that yourself and deforbs had a
particularly he was aware that he had a
particularly close relationship yes and
that's not what you said earlier as I
said I've never even have a cup of tea
with me like literally I know I've only
sorry I've only ever met her with her
lawyers and her accountants and he only
ever meet the DG and I can use the
previous DG whether something that in
your view why would either Mr Collins be
after that opinion or why would he
express it I have no idea whatsoever but
in your view then do you believe that he
intended to deceive this committee I I
honestly can't say I don't know and and
to be honest with you like there were so
many on shoots I just had to stop
looking and listen you know we were we
were under siege like unreal unreal well
I think clearly from the notes we've
received and I know we received them
late this morning they're quite
comprehensive yes in discarding what you
believe to be untruths like your
definition my definition of an untruth
is a lie it's a lie if it's not true
it's a lie sure so are you able to say
in your view that or to e lied
to this committee and those representing
them well as you said they were untrue
just well I think that's a careful
language well I think I don't need to be
careful chair because the definition of
an untruth
is Mr Kelly please Mr Curry
I think there's been a lot of lies
intentional and also I don't know sorry
you can just repeat that again I think
there's been a lot of lies and that's
why we're here intentional or not I I
don't know I I like again I I don't know
half of these people I
I I barely met them would have would
have been fair to say that given that
we've outlined our side of the story
today I would love the people to to
decide what the definition of it truth
or mistruth or lies in the sense that I
I would hope that they see some they get
some clarity today on that Mr tubberley
do you and has there been pre litigation
on your behalf both of your behalves
right no not at this point
thank you no thank you and I just well
then I I just want to clarify a number
of things you you're named Trish Whelan
Mr Kelly did Trish Williams work for
your office oh Sweden works is it or
illegal or to illegal and Katrina Fallon
she's in the legal department as well
okay
and just I want to go back because I
I've been trying to put myself in D
Forbes shoes for the past couple of
weeks
um I just want you to give me an outline
pre the 19th of December is there any
contemporaneous note of what gave rise
to that email or that meeting that took
place beforehand we start if I'm not
mistaken on the 19th of December
with with your documents oh sir
and it's proposed terms for new contract
and that's on the 19th of December
but I'm just I'm just looking from that
perspective where you where the starting
point was that gave rise
to the commercial relationship
the 75 000 commercial relationship
sorry I was just looking for the what so
what's what's the exact question so the
question is
yeah I'm I'm being in my head
to
figure out what it was that you put to
deforms that you say RTE came up with
the plan the scheme to give 75 000 like
what gave rise to it so
um
[Applause]
the sponsor Ortiz our biggest sponsor
and and and RTA wanted these events so
they came with the idea of the events
when they like where they'd happen when
they'd happen many late late Road Show
Ryan treble associations okay
RTE completely separate
um completely separate to the uh to the
contract
um okay to Ryan's Iranian super contract
we um I'm sorry and the first three were
drawn in year three because of covert
and then obviously this contractually
there's still a number six out so was it
the position that had that 75 000 not
been on the table that Mr Toby would
have walked from his country it's all no
right right Ryan has other contracts and
said with with BBC cover for different
people on BBC and he'd have his book
contract so there was no pressure put on
Miss Forbes in which there was another
you know you didn't say Mr Tolbert has
been offered a job in BBC and actually
quite the opposite
it was out there at those meetings Ryan
took 105 000 Euro pay code per annum so
that was the 525 000 so if we were
looking if that was the pressure point
you wouldn't have reduced you've heard
that so I'm just trying to ascertain why
Miss Forbes would give away effectively
75 000 Euros with which it really was
rte's public Revenue would you see would
you see it actually
so if I can just explain
um
so what the invoices were made at
artists they were directly email to RTA
and that's uh what was necessary to
plasma molasses
um well they're much further on I'm
trying to no no no no
so it's the first invoice was was
Renault
um but why she would so why she would
enter into an agreement well if if there
was why she first
I mean essentially that was in case the
sponsor again the sponsor relationship
is Authority now with us and for me what
that was about was if it was a new
sponsor in that during the duration of
the contract that we would be able to
work with with the next sponsor but it
was never an RTE payment it was Renault
and Renault were always paying the
invoice it was never meant to be already
to pay this ever yeah received it back
in terms of the the way the deal was
constructed the benefit of that 75 000.
what D Forbes has told us in the Public
Accounts committee previously like over
the last few years that the reason that
had to to pay pay these fees is because
the talent the Stars would walk but I
don't I don't want to divert to that in
10 minutes
yeah thanks very much uh koherlock and
I'd like to welcome our Witnesses
joining us today and thanks for being
here
Mr Kelly you you said today that Mr
tuberty is being met the poster boy uh
for this payment scandal
why is that the case is that the case
well intentional intentionally I I as I
said when
when the board and OT released the
statement
um without consulting us just having to
ask first and then not acknowledging
that there was no wrongdoing taking them
off here
then he was the face he was the face of
it do you know and that's where it
started and and it's been working in
this in its own vacuum for the last two
two and a half weeks where that's why we
wanted to come in we want to talk to we
want to tell you everything that we know
because it's been very hard looking at
so many untruths do you happily been
told yeah do you accept responsibility
that your actions have been reckless in
nature when dealing with authority on
this matter
no I don't we have just always followed
process of every single time
OT is at 350 million euro organization
the 100 in 2021 119 million would
license
this was commercial sorry Mr Kelly let
me let me so what's the next question
so you're trying to put the soul blame
on RTA here
in relation to in relation to this
payment Scandal yes completely and does
it not take two to tango Mr Kelly
but we were just far on process we were
we were just working on instructions for
more to you okay so so does it suit you
um and your client to keep things
ambiguous because we've heard a lot of
um statements already uh moody in the
water per se When Things become
difficult you can place the blame back
onto our team management I think that's
what's happening that's what happened in
this area this I I think as you know we
came ourselves here today this is the
first time we've had we've we've had to
actually a chance to actually talk
you have been engaged in Authority for
the past 23 years is that correct
how many people do you represent
um the top ten three
that's all
there's another region that represents
the other the other seven
so in relation to the the raising of the
invoices described for consultancy fees
I just want to clear up this man you
stated previously that Geraldine O'Leary
and rtu were responsible yes how is that
because it was under instruction from
them
okay because again the relationship with
Ortiz is it's a threat we have nothing
to do with Renault so so Mr Kelly you
were you were following instruction yes
so therefore did you con collude with rt
in a falsehood
of concealment of them invoices by
labeling yeah labeling them consultancy
fees
that's a straightforward question Mr
Kelly
I'm so sorry could you just
you said you were following the
instructions yes okay so therefore
did you collude with RTE in a falsehood
of concealment by describing them
invoices for a consultancy fees
and I said that
we had no benefits and sequence of the
press knowledge of any payments just
what this was fraudulent accounting
practices and we certainly didn't do any
fraudulent accountancy but you followed
instruction you never read this alarm
Bells Network never raised amongst you
representing your client in relation to
these sure again as I said we're smart
from eBay people
in his opinion described these as
defrauding the taxpayer do you agree
with that assessment
I didn't I didn't even hear that it said
that again do you still see these
invoices related to consultancy fees
these same voices were as instructed as
instructed and what were they for what
was the nature there were four
three minimum of three late shows what
they were intended for they were so in
the first invoice as you can see we were
instructed by ortegrated on the second
invoice to turn the voice we were just
following process do you accept the lack
of complete credibility to invoice a
company you never heard of in a
different country for work
undertaken here in Dublin I think the
lack of credibility is on ours on our T
side on RT side everything so how many
other deals were done with rt with your
business Mr Kelly when asked
to use a company from abroad that you've
never heard of before this this the road
shows the road shows were unique because
it was late late Ryan Renault RTE
Mr Kelly you're not taking any
responsibility for the oversight here of
Mr tolberty's earnings how are you in
relation to what we've actually been
told in this community room I don't
understand what you mean by oversight
are you taking any any responsibility in
relation to the oversight after dealings
with Mr tuberty in relation to these
invoices
you thought you said you followed
instruction yes from RTE yeah yeah
but your responsibilities on behalf of
your client did you not
proof test each of the steps that were
required my responsibility is absolutely
on my clients behalf and that's and
that's what we do
celebrity you said in your statement and
you emphasized the importance of Truth
uh the full truth and you you stated
that the full truth was concealed
okay so in your opinion and after what
we've listened to from Mr Kelly Do You
Believe
who do you believe was responsible for
concealing the truth
I believe
the person sitting to my left
and what he tells me I believe and and
what he's told you I believe
in your opinion do you think that's your
age included with RTE to conceal these
payments no
I think my agent did what what he was
instructed to do by orti
Mr toverty your earnings went up by 75
000 Euros in 2020 credited from Renault
on a side deal and then you received
another 150 000 Euros in 2022
underwritten
at the request
by RT yes so am I am I missing something
here
at a time between April 2020 and July
2020 yes when we were in the middle of a
pandemic
where you had taken a 20 pay cost on
your contract which was signed the first
of April yes and that these side deals
were undertaken at a time where the
country was going through
huge
um difficulty yes and you feel that
these payments should not have been put
into the public domain I I I was under
the understanding that payments that
come from Renault very very successful
commercial company so I didn't feel that
it was a naughty situation separate
contracts even though even though RTE as
we've heard from your agent was
responsible for the payment of these
invoices
yeah that's the misunderstanding that's
a misunderstanding like Renault paid the
first one under instructions to to send
the other ones so can I ask again who
suggested the side deal of any
description I don't know what you mean
by a side day the tripartite agreement
that was RTE RTE
and who wanted the underwriting in the
first instance the underwriting as I
said was simply about if the sponsor
changed if the sponsor changed
that's all
you never simple to be paying for
anything if the sponsor changed that
we'd be able to re-engage with the
sponsor relationship with the sponsors
Authority we know you're not allowed we
weren't allowed near us we have never
worked with render before we only worked
for them on this so
at a time Mr toverty you looked for uh
written assurances
in relation to any further pay cuts in
your 2020 contract
it
did you did you seek a written letter in
relation to that my no he didn't I did I
did
because having taken 105 000 Euros per
year by five five twenty five and not
accepting the 120 000 that he that he
was he was due in contract
I just said look you cannot when is the
contract to contract the contract is
only a contract when it's actually
agreed and honored on both sides RT
claimed that they've completely rejected
the claim of underrising the Reynolds
tripartite agreement
do you accept what they say in relation
to that and I bring it to the
the most important email here today is
on
um
so sorry page 10. of our book
and innocent says
um
and this is from the previous year but
we made good press good progress on what
the commercial agreement would be we
have to agree to one in Dublin two
outside Dublin again our director from
Ultimate what days is on that Mr Kelly
so um that was 20th of February 2020
which are so that was which are which
are OTA LED Late Late Show events we can
provide you with the side letter to
Android this fee for the duration of the
contract and the underwriting wasn't it
about finally networks it never like how
would we know our team we're going to be
playing for but the last was about was
if the contractor if the if the sorry if
the sponsor changed
Dash
we will be able to work with people
sponsored in regardless
thank you very much and to the witnesses
and look I should start for the effort
by saying we're very clear email at the
public Council committee to get to the
bottom of what's happening and certainly
your presence here today is very welcome
you've provided additional information
and I I thank you for that and I also
want to know Mr Toby that um uh in your
opening statement you say you have great
credibility or your great respect for
the institutions of this house and I
think that statement has great
credibility I've listened to you for a
long long time and I appreciate those
comments it's important the difficulty
that we have is is that
for whatever reason something happened
here and essentially RTE reduced its
income by 75 000 Euro
and in turn 75 000 Euro was paid to
Total Productions
um
yeah it was paid to Total Productions
albeit for additional duties on your
behalf so when are you whether who knew
what and when is really important
because that is essentially what happens
75 000 Euro over credit note was given
to Renault in return 75 000 was given to
your production company and you did
additional additional duties so it's
really important that we know who what
and that is why some of the information
you've given us is really crucial you've
said very clearly the one or two she
wished to lift is that you're an
independent contractor and I accept that
but would you accept that this
arrangement with RTE
um is not like at work you've gathered
from other companies like the BBC and so
on in essence RTA facilitated it it
introduced it to their clients they were
party to the agreement they uh the show
fault the events followed the Late Late
formats which is mentioned in in in the
agreement and RTA paid for the the
staging and the catering and so on so
it's not fair to compare this this
contract with other contracts that you
gain into early 70s would you accept
yeah that's a fair observation yeah okay
and so the suggestion is is that RTA
created this Arrangement yes in order to
bolster your income
I can't accept it as a matter of fact
because it's I think it is is it fair to
say that that we would as an independent
contractor you do different jobs for
different companies yeah like so for
example I've written a couple of books
with I'll be a you know one kid a couple
of kids books I don't know and and I
would have done as Nola said work in the
BBC before that's independent
contractory wouldn't have paid for it
occasion at the launch of those events
they wouldn't have provided staff they
wouldn't have had I understand your
Nuance of your point yeah so I think
it's it it's a fair point you make about
being an independent contractor but it's
not necessarily a relevant point to this
because this was an arrangement created
by RTE
according to your your evidence that
created by RTA yes and the net effect of
that was the taxpayer lost 75 000 Euro
and you gained this yeah well again this
is
whether you knew that was happening or
not it's a different question that is
what's happened if I can address the
first question relates to the state and
as a sponsor related showrunner or
perhaps the most important sponsor no
and all sponsors
um and the feed paper the sponsor lady
show will draw off any of the
sponsorship that they've had uh RT was
focused on keeping Renault happy
maximizing the potential of their
investment and The Late Late Show and I
think Geraldine earlier someone she's
here the other week then like and
certainly during covert there was their
tickets to the audience they know
tickets to the audience there's a green
room there's no green room so they were
trying you're way off point friends
do you appreciate that the state or
sorry that RTA lost 75 000 euro worth of
income as a fact and that Mr turbidi's
production company gained 75 000 as a
result of this tripod well no I I
completely disagree with that so you
can't disagree with that because that's
what actually happened I know but if I
can if I can yeah just for Marisol
please explain
um
as so the the first 75 was a paper was
paper around the figure of two two five
seven folders paper around another RTE
for delivery of three Banner Road shows
had nothing to do with Ryan's
broadcasting contract and the amount
claimed uh was their payments because
they'd issued a credit note we no no
idea about the Mission Credit notes I'm
gonna ask you how it arose Mr Ken just
for a moment sure I appreciate your
videos I'm asking how it rolls I'm
asking you do you accept that RTA
reduced its incompartmental by 75 000
Euro and that Mr Toby gained 75 000
Euros
sure I I I think uh with Orchard Renault
that's completely generation of course
exactly that's what our understanding of
what they do like as you can see so I'm
thinking that he accepted that's the
fact sure situation so we've no idea
what what Renault do in relation to
Ryan's contract it was well Mr Kelly the
crooks of the problem is
of course the problem is that that is
what actually happened and we need to
find out who knew that because it looks
like there's an attempt to to deceive
okay well then if that's if that's the
question we received as well okay saved
as well okay so are you both saying are
you both saying that and it's entirely
likely that you don't know are you both
saying you we're not aware that our the
Titan sponsored late show was reducing
its sponsorship by 75 000 Euro no so
that never came up that's not part of it
because the cost neutral nature of the
agreement is really important because
that's what really brings it down to the
core that money was taken off the books
and both of you are saying you have no
idea that Miss O'Leary's evidence she
said she raised the credit note to 75
000 Euro and she did that on the
instruction of Miss Forbes and you have
you said no idea no it is never formed
party if I need the current negotiations
and so on that's great okay look that's
important important important to get on
the table okay
distributed typically what that is is
that I suppose a lot of your colleagues
uh would would have taken reductions and
they would perceive that this additional
Arrangement facilitated arranged by RTA
was not in the spirit of uh what was
happening at the time I suppose you
wanted some point to go back into RTA to
go into the canteen to be able to look
in the eye of the person serving a cup
of coffee to talk down the mic of
somebody who there's a sound engineer at
the other end of it to look through the
lens of a camera
you have to be able to look those people
in the eye you're describing my friends
yeah but the facts of the situation
where that you received additional money
and they did not yes
and back to my opening statement
that cuts were made
through the years I think
all the reduction for 40. since 2012 40
which excludes 120. the final figure is
40 pay code 40 like I really
I want to turn to the invoice that was
raised
um so uh there's an email in your pack
page 25 uh which is appears to be from
uh somebody in RTA which says do not put
any person's name on the invoice if he
sends it back uh to me then I will sort
everything out who is that email from
um from Geraldine
it's oh sorry sorry it's from somebody
who worked for Geraldine so it's from an
RTA staff member yes can you provide us
with the name of that person
yeah
and it's it it's so um yeah okay it
looks very clear to me as somebody
responsible for public money that when
someone says in an email do not put any
person's name or invoice on the invoice
it's important for me to know who that
was I'd ask you to reflect on that and
if you can provide us the name uh I will
be asking or t the same question the
second question then is
on the 7th of May there was a a meeting
um a teams meeting um and there was four
people at that meeting can you tell us
who the four people were at that meeting
so that would have been
um Trish wheel and the OT one of the
Orchid solicitors deforms myself and a
colleague of mine leave
a colleague of yours so the fourth
person that we haven't been able to
identify so far was a colleague of your
own again useful information okay so I
then turn to uh the issue of the
invoices and I have to question Mr Kelly
here on this point because this is the
invoice for the first 75 000 Euro and
these are the invoices from the other
two 75 000 Euros yes one by now Cali the
other two by CMS yes one with the full
description the other two without the
full description yeah all relating to
the same 75 000 all relating to the
arrangement rental
you're the only one to raise these two
invoices it really strikes at The
credibility of what you're saying is
that you treated this separately from
this even though even after these
instruction you treated them separately
would that be fair
again we want to instruction as you can
as you can see description from OTA
description firm or GE referral to learn
your responsibility as director of your
company you raise two for the same three
payments you raise them under different
companies and you raise them for
different reasons and to invoice them to
dip to different people yeah and they
were they were sent under instruction to
RTE
um and we presume that at that uh runner
we're going to paint this okay last
Point uh you're very clear and you say
that you you should stress that NK
management had no idea who asked us
where they had no reason to think the
assets was linked to RTA and no reason
to believe that it was being made on
behalf of RTA would you be surprised
that your name is also mentioned
elsewhere in the assets accounts
this was what was this the rent the the
barter accounts yeah sorry so on the
30th of the 11th to 2018 uh there's a
reference to 2 394 Euro raised in
relation to a charity launch uh by Noel
Kelly in Aid of uh Chernobyl right
that's that's an RTE issue no but but my
understanding is that obviously a
fundraiser launcher I'm not sure
reflecting on the charity anyway sure
but it does strike to the to the heart
of your suggested that you didn't know
what as this was when there was a
previous Arrangement involving a charity
launch obvious where the astus account
was invoiced again deputy it's like well
perhaps you might help us uh if you can
tell us how that invoice uh was invoiced
in the past and it had no connection
would ask us your story Stacks up if
there's a previous invoice if you told
somebody to invoice asked us for the
lunch at the charity launch that you
held then the story doesn't so I'm not I
I don't have the facts before me I'm
just asking you the question I'm just
terrified that please
sorry just terrify that point for him
yeah and briefly the launching question
or she wants to take a table so they
um the people that were organized they
asked them to invoice that I I you know
RTE told the charity to invoice asked us
you didn't know it asked this was
invoiced no okay
no thank you sure
um
[Applause]
you say
stay where we're kind of active moments
because
um I read your documents and they were
too late it was insulting by the way for
the committee and for the staff
um
it didn't go down well but I did find
your documents uh quite compelling and a
very strong rebuttal
um on my initial thoughts
let's begin to fall apart a bit
orti and they're watching this obviously
indeed DJ is watching this the statement
that already issued this morning
is astonishing
if the DG is not watching this somebody
tell him that whoever issued this and
how it was issued because it's quite
obvious from the documentation of
fairness to yourselves that you provided
in relation to the
side payment or side deal as the email
for Marty from uh he says we can provide
you with a side letter to underrate this
fee for the duration of the contract
it's quite obvious
that that evidence is is very
competitive to our committee based on
dividends we've been given before by R3
and completely contradictory the two of
them totally opposite so that's a big
tick mark on on your side
however on the other side
um
there was no uh 20 drop in salary
in real terms
um and to say so has no credibility
whatsoever
zero given the 75k and and the various
different payments
um it was absorbed in a different way
that's quite obvious
the second issue which brings huge
amount of credibility is you must have
said Mr Kelly about 15 times you were
acting under instructions from RT in
relation to the payment processes
so the fourth payment
goes through Noel Kelly
one of your companies and that's right
now for first year the second one is to
address through CMS so why'd you switch
over Okay
um
what the real issue is you know I've
always these emails coming into me from
these whoever Nigerian cousins and I won
the lotto and they're instructing me to
do the following X Y and Z I don't do it
I think you've got serious accountancy
issues here
I think your companies have serious
accountancy issues here
based on what the evidence you're giving
here
because the fact is
this was not how companies behave
they get instructions to pay to an
anonymized unknown company
for something that's then referred as
consultancy fees
and under a contract that has been
negotiated with RTE for a private work
outside
and then switches from Noel Kelly to CMS
for the second and third year
none of this is credible
it doesn't stand up so that's where your
arguments are falling down now I want to
base some questions
firstly you talk about and you mentioned
the 20 and sorry sharp short answers
purely because the time not not trying
to be rude or anything
um the 20 drop
in the Years 2015 to 2019 then 2019 to
20. 23.
um I'll ask this question to Ryan
um
your work schedule so Mr Kelly has said
you took a 20 drop I think all of us
know here now that that ain't accurate
but
your work schedule where are you doing
the same amount of hours on all the
shows so are we comparing apples with
apples oranges with oranges was there a
change between 2015 to 2019 and 2019 to
23 in relation to your hours of work so
then we can correlate again across how
much of a drop impede there actually
really was based on ours worked you're
trying to establish the percentage of
the pay code I took in the years from no
I'm asking you this very simple question
I'm sorry
I know no it's not tiresome it's just
it's not my boss okay but but did you do
the same amount of hours on your radio
show and TV show from 2020 2019 to 2023
as you would do per year 2015 to 2019. I
wouldn't imagine so yeah okay so it is
the exact same yeah okay 205.
look for any changes in the contract to
lessen the amount of hours or lessen the
in time or anything like that I think
that there were conversations in so far
as and the big issue is that
so the longer the duration of The Late
Late Show the more space the more
advertising that actually goes inside
there's a pushback in relation we asked
if we could finish the Late Late At A
Hard half 11. so that would have been
two hours and two hours in the contract
but sometimes went down to 12 quarter
past 12 you know I know I know you know
the score it can go late but my point
being is was there any changes in
relation to ours in actual real terms uh
contractually on anything and you're
saying no no okay fine
um I just want to get back to the CMS
versus NK issue because I'm very
interested but Paula maludy's kind of
overlap of um
various different uh emails to
yourselves in relation to the other that
come true
um it's interesting that she
um she asks uh you they you confirm the
invoices or she asks about the invoices
uh in on May the third in relation to
the 275 thousands and um you know the
emails go to NK management
um but the responses from CMS the
response is information from CMS
my issue here is
CMS do they do or have CMS done a large
quantity of work with RTE separately no
no what is why would NK management
um why would that be swapped out and CMS
put in for payment purposes
communication purposes from a corporate
management point of view
let's say I own the two companies and
sometimes with invoice of whatever one
sometimes instead of another and then
cross invoice so there's no like Towing
your eyes to heaven sent the crossover
no no corporate governance point of view
do you think that from a corporate
governance point of view
again from an accountancy point of view
sure again we were asked to invoice we
were asked how to invoice went to
invoice yeah but sorry no I'm going to
be straight I don't buy any of that I
don't think anybody listening watching
here in this room buys that as I've said
earlier on it's not it's not
uh I think Deputy Dylan that's the
acoustic went through this
um
this is not appropriate and how things
should be done
okay
um
so in relation to NK management can you
tell us uh there was a new company set
up Noel Kelly management nominees
limited registrated on the 16th of March
2023. this is a third company yeah and
what's the purpose of that
um I didn't I didn't I'm not here to
discuss that okay
but there's nothing to do with anything
to do with it yeah
it's not obviously good right that's
fine in relation to
um so from your from your uh perspective
as regards you sell uh you get
advertising clients into RTE on the one
hand
and obviously you represent various
different clients agent as an agent to
the stairs or Talent whatever phrase
people are using these days on the other
happened
so there must be significant you're
doing significant amount of business for
RT as regards generating advertising
revenue on the one hand
and obviously negotiating fairly
significant contracts for your clients
who work in RT on the other hand is that
a fair statement no no no no no so
for instance
um
we have we have a young Chef on our
books and um sorry if you just sorry no
but I just I'm just trying to explain
the young Chef in our books and then we
got that Chef a book deal right so now
the chef's an author yeah and then we
got the chef at a TV show some of the
money that wrote so the issue is there's
there's a huge lack of funding for
program making so we would try and get
sponsors to help make but you do get
sponsors for RT to for advertising
purposes would it be for completely
independent shows
give me this information I'd be asking
RT for the last 10 years just on
advertising and clients all of that so
we'll be will we get another sure last
three very quick questions to Ryan
um earlier your agents uh your
representative Mr Kelly said a contract
isn't a contract unless it's agreed by
both parties so how do you stand
currently as regards your relationship
with RTE are you implied or not how do
you perceive that that's the first
question second question you can take
these down of course second question is
in in relation to in relation to
um the one of the gigs with Reynolds
there was a an invoice for 847 for
somebody to be assist you or something
you might draw a light on that because a
number of us would and thirdly and this
genuine honest question
um Thai Soldier musical has been an
unmitigated disaster right conceptually
in every way In fairness to you you had
zero to do with it right
um You didn't promote it bitcoin's
involvement but
from the outset did you think that this
was a disaster and a bad idea and you
didn't want anything to do with it
they're my three last questions just
just briefly Mr Torres on all three yeah
just very briefly
um I I my understanding is I am still in
contract with authority yes and my aim
and hope is to go back to work
um the uh the billing you referred to
was a car service from Dublin to
drogheda and back all in one night I can
go into further detail if you wish but
that's what that is for you or for
somebody else oh no for me okay and
thirdly and finally The Toy Show the
musical I think that the people in RT
were trying to dream big I always wished
them well with that but it wasn't for me
okay thank you Murphy
you and you're very welcome thank you
Debbie um the uh just want to go back to
the invoice
um and like invoices are not Mr Kelly
are not a creative document they're
intended to be a true record to say what
a service what service has been provided
or what work has done
so essentially both sides were complicit
in what the chair of the the board said
you know designed to deceive
um and
so like
do you accept that or did you challenge
that you know that this
we were to see if we we no longer just
over the arrangement which you wish with
the invoice it's like you know but if I
could just explain we weren't consultant
about it nobody told us any stage of the
nature and we went structured by our
team for the second and third invoices
of the better Roadshow to make out the
invoice to artists the consultancy
services we sent them to RT to look out
you'll have a number of companies you
know what it is to raise an invoice you
did you you took instructions from art
without without challenge
um and essentially there's there's a
moral and legal imperative around that
um you know essentially um and I'd like
to ask Mr charity can I just finish that
at the time we didn't know who asked us
was
they had a relationship with Renault and
we were following instructions I want
this and we got paid yeah
follow instructions
you know Mr tuberty
um would you would you be happy with
that kind of of arrangement not being
challenged because it was being done in
your name Deputy Murphy I I will tell
you that my involvement in anything I've
not I haven't not I'm not sat down in
front of an RT management person in 20
years to talk about money contracts
anything like that whatsoever that's why
I have Mr Nella Kelly are you are you
happy with just following instructions
in relation to like you know what an
invoice is I mean
honest to goodness I don't
get into invoices and that kind of thing
my job is to sit in front of a
microphone and present a radio to our TV
show honest to goodness I so I I trust
no he trust the process we all we all
hope to get the best 16 in life it's
really not the question I'm asking I
want to go back to the um Grand torrent
and are conducting a second review into
000. we know there was a 225 that's the
75. they're they're conducting uh
another review into the 120 000 that's
2017 to 2019. you're saying
categorically that just simply was
waived it wasn't paid and RT knew that
RT knew that
do you have any explanation why they
would be conducting an expensive review
into that I have no idea we um
we have a further meeting with Grant
Thornton on that we asked RTE and let me
one second I just
[Applause]
mm-hmm
sorry I could come in there if you like
that in in discussions with LRT in March
2020 they indicated to us that they were
going to treat
um this in their accounts and they said
for accountancy reasons that they were
going to take the 120 off the previous
three years contracts so that's 50 in
year 550 in year four uh 20 and year
three extraordinary figures and we said
that this didn't make any sense as we
had neither invoice or received or
refunded the uh 120. so how could it be
deducted then this is the question you
uh we were posing to them saying this
seems kind of mad and Ortiz proposed
treatment of this would would give the
impression that I was being paid 120 000
or less than I was actually playing we
made it clear Deputy that uh the 120 000
should not be taken off or deducted for
prior year actual earnings as you can
see in your booklet on pages 14 and 15.
and already appeared to agree with our
point and it accepted our amendments in
the final letter of agreement on this
issue again page 16 of the documents
provided however on the 21st and 3rd of
January when the top 10 earners were
published RTE appears to have reverted
oddly to their original stance and
deducted the 120 000 as they originally
said they would do so we were obviously
very surprised to see that
nice okay just um in in relation to the
um you did open by saying that you're a
contractor and we think we all know an
independent independent contractor but
RT wouldn't normally find you work as an
independent contractor
um you know and that's why it is it's
not ordinary this is not ordinary and
that's how it's impossible for us to
separate out I understand the the
difference between the random Renault
contract and your and your salary yes
because effectively it would be RTE
finding new work where you would
normally find that work yourself again
I would
hand this to Noel because he's the one
who who finds the work if you will and
and you're going to negotiates the the
contract side of things okay the the
value
um with Renault or authority is keeping
Renault happy as a sponsor keep him on
board and and making sure that they they
come back season after season so that's
really why OT wanted to to do this yeah
they're the biggest sponsor that the
actually the biggest sponsor that we
actually have so yeah can I just ask you
so I'm very sure of the time can I can I
and I'm trying not to be but it's just
uh
did you know Mr Kelly that's the that
Reynold had insisted on the commercial
agreement was done on a course neutral
basis no I had no idea because that's
um
because we we invoice we invoice ran up
we had no idea
no idea just
um
uh in relation to D like Mr Kelly who
would you normally deal with when you're
dealing with you know the contractual
reactions for your your clients and it
depends really um like some of our
contractors might do eight one half hour
shows in a year and that's it so but you
wouldn't normally deal with the the
directory no no that would only be on on
on bigger contracts so generally it
would be the head of head of uh radio
and so something sometimes it's just
radio only you do have one hour radio
show once a week or you might do so you
know so DeForest was not the only one
that would would have been aware of all
of this we've been told
um no absolutely that was only one
person
couldn't have been couldn't have been
that's why I find this whole thing so
bizarre but but in relation to so so
some of our some guys might just have a
one-hour like a one hour radio contract
someone have a TV contract somebody have
a bit of radio and a bit of TV and so it
would depend
head of TV under ahead of TV executive
MDA TV MD radio it would just depend
where it would sit and then you'd have
an overall like uh Alan Tyler and uh uh
when he was saying like he's head of
entertainment sorry I have very little
time sorry sorry so I'm just saying
there's so many people like there's 1800
people in the organization so so many
people you don't operate for 1800 people
you're in no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
um the uh reader O'Keefe's statement
last week
um she she said that when I left in
March 2020 an RTE guarantee on the
proposal the proposed Reynold agreement
was not uh on on offer as far as where
so she's linking in the the Renault
agreement with the the salary
um and you can see why this keeps on
coming back to this same team
um and and you have in your booklet I
think on page seven the the email from
um and was there other correspondence
because this then wasn't finalized until
May yeah um and the RTE statement this
morning is telling us that
um that the 20 the February agreement uh
was is being characterized as a
contractual commitment
um
I I I if I can explain
the whole purpose of this it wasn't
about contract not contract the whole
purpose of this was
other people know other people know Bar
D Forbes that's the whole point and all
along and it was said to you like the
week before last Central to this nobody
else knew nobody else knew it was no
there was no secret there was no secret
this is the this is the this is the
sacred piece so there was no secret
whatsoever whatsoever we don't
you know there's no secret I mean given
all or you know all you've listened to
over the last few weeks
um
um and and you say you want to go back
and work on the radio
it seems to me that looking at it from
your perspective that appears to come
across strange given the given the uh
you know all of the issues that you've
documented in your in in your booklet
and the opening stage what what's
strange excuse me sir like what I want
to go back to an organization that you
obviously feel has badly uh damaged you
I've been badly damaged by the last
three weeks to be honest with you but
not necessarily by RTE as an institution
I think there are people that I'm dying
to get back to work with like most
decent Irish people and they're making a
an honest living and they're working
hard to pull to get together the shows
and I want to be back with them I had my
beef obviously with with some people
there is obvious in the documents but
uh I still see my future there yeah okay
okay thank you very much I just want to
take the opportunity to welcome both of
you here and I think it's important to
reference that you were not compelled to
be here which is which is obviously
welcome
um Mr property the first question I have
for you is when you have a major guest
coming on the show how often how long
does it take you to prepare for that
well uh that's that's it forgive me it's
a lot of questions do you mean on the
night of a show or I thought it's a good
question I just want to ask how long
does it take you to prepare for a major
act coming on the lately it takes it
takes days and weeks okay this is a 39
page document which is for people who
are not aware what it looks like this
this document was provided to us this
morning this came into our Microsoft
teams account this morning at age 23 uh
if I'm correct right 59 Pages yes
the meeting commenced at 10 30 in
private session here today yes that's
not that much time I understand you
accept just one second yes can you
accept how
that's it's not physically possible for
anybody here to comprehensively go
through the information that was that
was that was unfortunate and and I I
have to say I do apologize to every
single member of the committee for that
uh it has been a tortuous three weeks
no no but unfortunately you have to
there's what's gone missing in the last
three weeks you can hear like forgive me
yeah just briefly there's been a
Humanities bypass a bit here
okay so I just think just just bear with
us
we have worked tirelessly to put this
document together
okay and we got it in when we could and
I apologize thank you look I appreciate
your apology and accept it and you know
what from purely from a human
perspective I think all of us here
understand this is difficult we're
politicians we know what it's like okay
to be to be to be dragged through the
river and unfortunately you know this is
the next point of questioning I wanted
to come to anyway Mr property so you you
have you have moved on to that uh
properly look the reason this has
erupted is because of the work that was
done by the report by the orders that
was identified that identified the pay
arrangements and which we've discussed
already with the Executive Board of RT I
just want to get a clear picture when
did you first become aware of the I
suppose issues that were were brought to
light through uh the orders that was
carried out when did you first get
knowledge of that order has been carried
out I'm gonna say
what are we on now July
June maybe just when you started to to
be honest with you when this state would
not they changed the statement was when
I really became engaged in this story I
had no idea I think that's really
important I'm not trying to trip you up
no I appreciate that I'm aware that that
report was being carried out pardon me
I'm sorry I'm just asking once again I
just want to ask you in relation to the
report that was coming yes yes of course
when did you become aware of the grand
Tartan report the 26th of June 2023 okay
so the 26th of June 2023 was the very
first time that you had knowledge that I
had done before it was been done and can
I ask that in relation that the same
question relation to Mr Kelly obviously
if they were delving into the pay
Arrangements which they did highlight
concerns with was this was that the same
for you no
um
for us it was uh in may we had a meeting
with Grant Thornton and there was
there's the May 23 is that correct yeah
May 23 that we've been meeting with
Grant Thornton
um is that the first time that documents
were requested from your agency your
company in relation to Mr properties pay
um on the 3rd of May
um Orchard League or emailed us
and asked us about invoice queries on
the 26th of May orchie legal road to us
and said the grand portion were
investigating process 31st of May we met
with ground Taunton and discussed
everything with them and on 23rd of June
zurchie's first statement on the 26th of
June and we we only received the report
we only received them for it on the 26th
of June we didn't get a copy of the
report
the 22nd of June when the statement came
out from from RTE
um uh the statement and then they
released the report we didn't even have
the report yeah and so at that stage
that's what we were saying so so that
happened on the Thursday and then it was
four days later before the correction
said that there was no wrongdo and we
have to interpreting ourselves and then
at that stage one was our fair and said
the whole thing so had had they what did
you say not be so Hasty or uh they
hadn't rushed everything out 99 of this
whole thing wouldn't be an issue because
we would have given them everything they
wanted if they simply asked questions
the reason I went there for them the
reason I want to ask you this question I
think it's for your own benefit Mr
tuberty Right and I know that you may
feel it being somewhere indignant with
you but I'm not not at all I totally
understand what's the reason I'm asking
it is because it's crucial but gross
understanding and verifying your
information there was nothing to do with
your decision step down from The Late
Late Show sorry that's why I'm asking
you you're trying to clarify the latest
no no I have that's terrified I'm I'm
content I'm happy the next thing I want
to move on to is in relation to the deal
surrounding um uh renaults so in 2012
the first year of the deal Craig was
over quite to say it was 20 21 wasn't
that right yeah the first year should
have been 2020 and that would have been
20 21 to up to up to 24
um but obviously with covert there was
no events on 20 or 20 ones the first lot
of events actually happened in 22 when
we had the Forest Road shows out out in
in Cork Dublin drogheda and in Trent so
at what stage were you informed by
Reynolds that Reynolds that they were
not going to continue on with their part
of the deal in relation to in relation
to the pandemic the outbreak of the
pandemic and their withdrawal from that
and subsequently RTE stepping in and
providing the the funding to fill in the
Gap no they never step back from the
arrangement Brenner still Runner was
still the sponsor and it was like no
stage was it going to be RTA but when I
say a step back from the arrangements
that we as we've discussed here already
the money was paid by RTE that that 75
000 correct no the money was paid by
Renault yes but in terms of the later
the latter half of that were made they
were paid by asked us they were paid by
assets yes yeah yeah yeah which
effectively that's what we need to get
an understanding of what work was done
in return for that in the in the later
years during the last 22 sure so as I
said the first three that were supposed
to be doing 20 were done in 22 so
there's still six Road shows owed for
for for 20 and 21 or if you if you if
you're like 23 24 so they're still
they're still under contract to do those
Road shows so you're saying to me that
those are old
you're paid in advance
no I must ask from it from the point of
view of reputational damage right and I
think this is key did you not assess
going into the pandemic in in and we all
know how difficult it was and you
broadcast to wrote them drove us um with
General gray admiration respect for the
population well did you
in any way say Joseph this is a
dangerous situation because the
published figures in relation pertaining
to my salary that have been published in
newspapers I think the version knows
that the argument were publishing those
Figures were not reflective of your
actual take-home pay and I have heard
the evidence you provided and what
you've said yes at the end of the day
there was a three-partered agreement
there involving the national broadcaster
in RT with Renault and yourselves but
did you not ask us if the question maybe
it's just not wise for me to be taking
this money at this point in time
considering what was going on in the
country yep I think it's a fair it's a
fair observation and I probably should
have been a bit more inquisitive about
these things you've never asked any
questions in relation to that I'd say
when I say I should have been more
inquisitive
exactly can I just answer there
um
this conflict was written before covert
before covert so it's just been covered
happened so that this was the start in
in 2020.
to be fair of my line of questioning is
reflecting that but I'm just asking in
relation to the outbreak of Culver's
which is really necessary
that's
this arrangement in some shape or form
remains in place where ultimately you
know the extract the taxpayers money
involved an RT is an organization who's
been used to supplement specific
properties income that's the perception
here we need to deal with no that's the
perception but that's not the reality
okay this was a contract with Renault
for services at RT and Renault are again
are are are are there other parties
those Services were not provided yeah
to be honest with by 2022 they all would
have been provided if the if covert
wasn't there for Years sir we know that
so now the six so now the six
uh Road shows owed okay can I just ask
in relation to the negotiations are on
pay this is important because we did
discuss it with the RT executive board
they were not very forthcoming with
answers I know there is a very a very
wide Chasm between the information that
you provided us today with us today and
what they've given us previously but I
want to ask who in the executive board
of RTE was involved in those paying
negotiations who in the executive course
was present and involved
again you'd have
um had a TV had a radio they'd you know
say right we want these areas we want
those errors and then they discussed
that with uh with the the CFO with with
the relevant accountants under as I said
that there's there's lots of accountants
and I know or something else so they
would all have the conversations and
then they would come back and my job is
to get the best deal from I'm so sorry
you know didn't answer my questions
from the Executive Board of art for
these negotiations
Frida Trish so the CFO and legal and and
then if there was an impasse sorry
um if there was an impasse take a minute
to read it it's okay sure so sorry so
you'll have a predo Keith deforbs
ourselves our lore
um and Jim Jennings from the executive
okay
come back okay thank you so we have to
finish at two o'clock okay so I just
have some questions myself I want to ask
um just Mr Healthy um the number of uh
number of presenters your represented
already he said three of the top ten
money in total do you represent many
many people engaged with rt do you
represent
Oh north
is it 20. wait what no no not at all the
the the ones that we really represented
Mario we're looking at I don't don't
delay the answer is we would represent
full color so full contract will be
something we had TV and radio yeah
um that's three and then there would be
other people who might just do
and one hour series or whatever
no it wouldn't be it's six it'll be it
should be near to like I'd say three
foot full time and then the rest will
just be part-time or and how would you
describe your trade
are you a negotiator are you a
consultant you know what what type of
work have you done would say my
background would be would be marketing
and Brands and sales and and sales and I
see people as Brands and how how you
take you know a young a young talent and
tell them to me time to me is like it's
every it's it's
potentially is the person behind
reception makes you feel like today the
people that make us feel welcome when
you come in that's a talent that the
camera people that the floor people that
tell it to me isn't isn't like a rock
guard it's not like a uh
we'll all agree on that one yeah we're
just just in relation to your your you
know the type of so you come from a
sales background yes
sorry what kind of goods would you would
you have sold what kind of marketing
would you have been just wrote just
briefly so I have this company
um
CMS for uh 26 years before I worked for
Cadbury's
um
Sorry probably sell them for countries
yeah chocolate chocolate okay
thank you thank you thank you it's fine
it's soap anyway well that's fine thank
you
and tell me this your relationship with
d Forbes yes
um the senior staff at RTE Dave
described that she had a very close
relationship yeah
well if a close if a close relationship
is in a room with lawyers and
accountants and not a cup of tea between
it never had math for lunch never met
for dinner I don't know the lady I've
always learned to be terribly
professional I'm working hard during
covert and everything else I don't know
the lady and I would only ever meet
deforms if there was an impasse and you
know in a contract or where we're at or
what can we do you know so so I don't
know her should we take sorry I I've met
her but I like I I you know I'm sorry
but I was respectful to you but you
can't put my background selling
chocolate yeah and now you're now you're
negotiating on behalf of the tough
starters in the country you know and
great success to you for that okay uh in
terms of you know in terms of uh deals
obviously you know how deals are done uh
and this is always been fascinating I
think in a lot of people's minds in
terms of you know the leverage that you
have we'll say with in terms of when
you're negotiating what tell me briefly
what that leverage story is from because
RT have told us previously in this
committee room the public accounting
commission sure that
uh Mr turpity another you know very
popular Stars yeah uh very good at her
job would walk right you have said no
that's not the case here today so what's
the setup where does that Leverage come
from so
um I'd say exactly where and tell me
it's supposed to say
I come from a world-class background I
come from very very hard working class
background both my parents worked very
hard and all they ever said to us was
you work hard and then you work harder
and if you want something then you work
then you then your card again so for me
except that so so for me personally I
don't have leverage I I manage people
that have no management I manage people
that have no Union that have no
Representatives I I I I work with people
that have cheers sure sorry sorry
anybody who's ever done a bit away and
then dealing with naughties right when
you were sitting there you know and
whoever blinks first right and you're
there and you're negotiating with the
with the top Finance people or legal
people or indeed with the director
General
where does that leave reached away from
because there's a clear contradiction
between your position right and you come
from the background and says you know
and you get selling chocolate and you're
not being raised taxes and fair play New
York you walked away yeah yeah right but
um uh you know where does that Leverage
come from you're not giving me an answer
to this I don't understand what you mean
where does the power in other words your
partner in power you need partner and
power when you're feeling a deal and
when you're you know when you're
involved in sales when you're involved
in negotiations oh sorry sorry
Mr Kelly no let me clarify your
involvement you know what I'm talking
about here yeah you're involved in
serious negotiations and don't minimize
this right on behalf of course
the leverage and power derive from it
you know it's not libatur it's all based
on facts and it's all based on figures
and commercial reality and that's what
it's based on and over the periods of
those six years from 2012 to 2020 Ryan
turbury's shows now you could say
somebody else could do the show and all
of that so it's like a bunch of these
shows over that sixth period with the
team completed hugely the team I mean
the team it's a jigsaw of time so he
took over those six years going to be
brought in 100 million in commercial
revenue and In fairness it's a hugely it
was a hugely successful commercial
operation they did like in 2008
million absolutely purely in comparison
I'm not licensed so it's a it's a your
voting that pretty well and thanks for
that so just just in relation to some
people in RT you know we have looking at
some of the documents come across me
that you have significant influence and
significant
power in terms of the internet RTE and
some people you know been more than once
over the years been said to me the real
director General RT is Noel is Noel
Kelly is you
um
no it's I've just that's what that's
what's been said not by somebody you
know not by somebody on the street
corner this is supposed to people who
are working in RTE okay so it's you know
it's a it's so ridiculous we do deals
right I mean and we do contracts okay
for for our people you know I might be
an RTE six times six times in a year you
know but but equally we do we would be
working with BBC NBC you know so it's
nice kind of move to one of those deals
for a moment just in relation to the
Renault deal to try to hard to heal
yourself is Renault an RTE
actually a it's a one-year deal from
from October 2020 to December 21.
um
so we've been told from the start that's
a three-year deal but it wasn't a
three-year deal it's here in front of me
have it here okay I read it read it
carefully
that uh is a three-year three-year deal
or intended to be a tree or the year
but that's that's not seen in contract
anywhere there's nowhere in the contract
it was intended to be a five-year deal
yeah we signed a contract right and can
I ask you this and that's and you would
you would be used to signing contracts
right
uh why why did you expect RTE Turner
right it for for three years whenever
when this is only a one year deal again
um
the relationship is with Renault the
sponsor I still Renault and RTE and all
I actually want them all I want them to
write was that if the sponsor no you're
signing the deal and you know that
unless it's nailed down in that signed
on the throttle line right it doesn't
stand for anything
it's not correct you would know that we
we have these videos
we had a separate contract okay for Ryan
to do this outside of his regular TV why
is figure mentioned in in it there is no
figure mention of 73 000 Brandon well
why is that sorry in the pack
um in the invoice and the instructions
your minimized letter right you minimize
the earlier on the meeting to document
primary document is the tripartite
agreement that's what it is
so why so here we have a document that
with no figure mentioned in it not
signed up for a three year deal but
you're working on the basis has
three-year deals right uh and
the other question I would ask you is
that why and I haven't heard a clear
explanation for this why this is only
signed on the 21st of April this year
when the 10 10 20 hit the fan because it
was a working document the first one was
supposed to be 20 then 21 22. so that's
that's why to be honest it was a working
documenting so far as it was about Mr
Kelly you're asking me and the committee
and the public to believe here today and
just let me tell you what you're asking
to believe there's ask them to believe
that your assignment that you'll enter
into an agreement not
excuse me not saying to this year right
Connor is one three years without having
to nail down legally and without the
signatures of your agency
but the agreement uh kerlock came from
RTE to us no no it will get hurt again
for me you you were an agent right a
professional agent right and people say
you're very successful at it you mean to
tell me that you've entered into this
without this haven't been tied down for
three years because that's the effect of
it you did not sell uh Neve McCormick
signed it on 21st after board on behalf
of you and Mr tuberty 24th to the Ford
23. I'm going to ask you this an RT
never sounded
signature on it
and let me just say this Theory what's
also incredible is the second last Lane
in the agreement says one signed by all
parties disagreement will constitute a
legally binding agreement a legally
bonded document and acknowledged that
there is a valid consideration for this
agreement once the Saint Paul parties
now you're telling me you went along in
a wing in a prayer with four major
faults in this no signatures not signed
signed this year you know no figures
mentioned in it not a three-year deal
and you were happy as a professional
agent to sign off on this you ask me to
believe that
the whole the contract in total was
brokered between that but the
Consciousness Authority in Renault and
we were the third part of this contract
we agreed for 75 thousand years for a
separate contract to provide those
services and that's what that's what we
did and Mr Kelly you don't sign into
contracts you know and I know that you
don't sign contracts or you don't enter
into agreements or contracts on the
basis of a document like that you know
that I may not correct in saying that
but RTE had brokered the contract I
don't care who brokered it you you're
telling me that you went along for three
years on a wing and a prayer that's just
that's what you're expecting us to
believe here no and I don't believe that
okay
obviously the events were pushed out
because of code I don't care what was
pushed out there was nothing to stop it
from coming in an envelope and saying
that it could have been sent by Courier
to a year and you could have signed it
right back at that time which you didn't
and the figures weren't in it and the
three-year Dimension wasn't in it that's
the facts
well the deal was broken by RTE thank
you
thank you okay
so look we've gone through a lot of
questions and we have to finish because
In fairness that your Witnesses in first
you have come voluntarily you know your
country three hours of question and I
know Mr strawberry I'm Australia person
three more hours in the afternoon so I
want to be fair to you you need a break
of an hour right so I'm going to um uh I
want to thank you for attending I also
want to thank the controller for General
James McCarthy and his staff for
attendant is it agreed that the Clara
could seek any follow-up information and
carry out any agreed actions arising
from the meeting agreed okay uh it's
also agree that we know it and published
the opening statements and brief
material provided for today's meeting
and a welcome to factor in order long I
wanted I wanted you to be able to read
out your side of it yeah that was
important an hour or five minutes before
I go can I just briefly say just just to
say uh thank you to the committee for
the courtesy which which they've
afforded us with their questions today
I'm sure there are more pressing issues
in the world but at the same time that's
not to belittle what we were talking
about today thank you for your time
many times that is really important to
hear your side as I say we respect the
Iraq thank you thank you for that so the
meeting of the property councilman is a
journal from nine turkey and Torres said
turkey thank you very much thank you
very much
[Music]
so foreign assistance
that every word and work of ours may
always begin from thee in by thee be
happily ended through Christ Our Lord
amen
we now take leaders questions
understanding order 36 I call logivity
peer star deeply
Hospital Nations